THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
ARCHULETA.
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES.
BELL. FOR JUST.
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CARILLO [inaudible]
CHIANG.
DODD MORNING ROWS OF GALGIANI
YES GLAZER GROVE.
HERTZBERG.
HILL.
HUESO -- TITLE [inaudible]
JACKSON JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MONNING [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROCK.
RUBIO SKINNER.
STERN [inaudible]
STONE.
I'M BURKE.
Y. CASKEY.
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
THANK YOU MISTER SECRETARY A
QUORUM IS PRESENT WITH THE
MEMBERS HAD OUR GUESTS BE ON THE
RAIL AND IN THE GALLERY PLEASE
RISE WE WILL BELEAD IN PRAYER
THIS MORNING BY OUR CHAPLAIN
SISTER MICHELLE GORMAN.
AFTER WHICH PLEASE REMAIN
STANDING WE WILL BE LED IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG
BY SENATOR MITCHELL.
ON THE BACKS OF ALL.
LET US CENTER OURSELVES IN GOD'S
PRESENCE.
THIS PRAYER IS PRAY TO EACH
MORNING BY HIS HOLINESS THE
DALAI LAMA.
AND IT COULD ALSO BE A PRAYER OF
OUR MOTHERS.
MAY I BE A GUARDS FOR THOSE WHO
NEED PROTECTION.
A GUIDE FOR THOSE ON THE PATH.
A BOAT OR RAFT A BRIDGE FOR
THOSE WHO WISH TO CROSS THE
FLOODS.
MAY I BE A LAMP IN THE DARKNESS.
A RESTING PLACE FOR THE WEARY.
A HAILING MEDICINE FOR ALL WHO
ARE SICK.
A VASE OF PLENTY.
A TREE OF MIRACLES.
AND FOR THE BOUNDLESS MULTITUDES
OF LIVING BEINGS.
MAY I BRING SUSTENANCE AND
AWAKENING.
AND DURING LIKE THE EARTH AND
SKY.
UNTIL ALL BEINGS ARE FREE TO
FROM SORROW.
AND ALL OUR AWAKENS AMEN AMEN.
COLLEAGUES PLEASE JOIN ME AS WE
ALL SALUTE OUR FLAG.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE.
OF THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
AND TO THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT
STANDS. ONE NATION UNDER GOD
INDIVISIBLE WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL.
MY COLLEAGUES WE'RE GONNA MOVE
DIRECTLY TO PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR SENATOR ATKINS.
THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
IF I COULD -- AND I APPRECIATE --
THE OPPORTUNITY TO HONOR AND
RECOGNIZE TODAY MISTER JEFF GUYS
SO.
ON THE SENATE FLOOR AS HE BEGINS
THE NEXT CHAPTER IN HIS CAREER
AFTER TWO DECADES WITH THE
LEGISLATURE.
JEFF HAS BEEN A MAINSTAY IN THE
SENATE FOR THE LAST DECADE MOST
RECENTLY AS DIRECTOR OF THE
SENATE DEMOCRATIC CAUCUS FOR THE
PAST FIVE YEARS.
AND CHIEF OF STAFF TO THEN STATE
SENATOR NOW CONGRESSMAN TED LIU.
BEFORE THAT NOW LET ME JUST SAY
SOMEBODY WROTE THIS FOR ME.
HE'S BEEN A LOST DECADE IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
AND NOW AS A FORMER SPEAKER
SITTING NEXT TO A FORMER SPEAKER
I'M NOT SURE A 100% AGREE BUT
HEY IT'S OUR BENEFIT TODAY -- HE
BEGAN AS AN INTERN WITH
ASSEMBLYMAN FRED KEY LEE.
RISING THROUGH THE LEGISLATIVE
MOSH PIT TO SERVE AS AN AIDE AND
THEN A CONSULTANT TO JEROME
HORTON.
AND THEN THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE OF
MEMBER SERVICES.
I KNOW THAT MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
DEMOCRATIC SIDE OF THE AISLE
WILL MISS HIM DEARLY HE'S PLAYED
AN INSTRUMENTAL ROLE IN THE
GROWTH AND SUCCESS OF THIS
CAUCUS.
MY REPUBLICAN FRIENDS NOT SO
MUCH -- BUT ALL IN GOOD FUN.
JEFF I HOPE THAT THE NEW ROLE
ALLOWS YOU MORE TIME WITH YOUR
INCREDIBLE SPELLS ROBIN.
AND YOUR TO ADORABLE DAUGHTERS
WHO ARE WITH YOU HERE TODAY ROSY
AND ELEANOR SET WAVE IT ROSY AND
ELEANOR.
YES.
BUT OF COURSE THEY CAN ALWAYS
VISIT YOU IN YOUR NEW OFFICE AT
SIMON'S.
COLLEAGUES.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN OFFERING OUR
SINCERE THANKS AND
CONGRATULATIONS TO JEFF CASA.
A WARM.
RELATIONS IN PEOPLE'S THANK YOU
FROM THE DEMOCRATIC PROCESS
. FOR
THOSE WHO WOULD LIKE TO GATHER.
FOR THIS WOULD BE A GREAT MOMENT
TO DO THAT.
AND PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT THE
CHILDREN ARE FRONT AND CENTER
.
AND THANK YOU AGAIN MR GOD SO
AND FAMILY. FOR YOUR YEARS OF
SERVICE [inaudible]
SENATOR BRADFORD.
SENATOR BRADFORD UNDER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
WANT TO TAKE THIS OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOGNIZE.
A SPECIAL INSTITUTION FOR MY
DISTRICT CHARLES TO UNIVERSITY --
THAT GRADUATES MORE MINORITY
MEDICAL STUDENTS NURSES PRIOR
THAN ANY OTHER INSTITUTION IN
THIS NATION AND THEY'RE HERE
TODAY -- AND LED BY DR CARLISLE
SO PLEASE STAND TRIALS TO
UNIVERSITY MEDICAL SCHOOL AND
STUDENTS WARM WELCOME.
TO OUR GUESTS FROM DREW
UNIVERSITY.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
SENATOR GROVE.
AT THE PRO TEM'S DESK.
GOOD MORNING GOOD MORNING MADAM
PRESIDENT THANK YOU.
COLLEAGUES IT'S MY PLEASURE THIS
MORNING TO INTRODUCE TO
DISTINGUISH OFFICIALS FROM
GEORGIA AND UKRAINE.
THEY'RE SPENDING ONE MONTH
INTERNING IN THE OFFICE OF
LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AS PART OF
THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S
PROFESSIONAL FELLOWS PROGRAM.
CENTER GROVE SKEWS ME ONE MOMENT.
WHAT A NOISE IN THE BACK IF YOU
COULD KEEP IT DOWN PLEASE AND
DRAW YOUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR
GROW FOR HER PRESENTATION?
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AS I
WAS SAYING THERE SPENDING A
MONTH IN INTERNET IN THE OFFICE
OF LEGISLATIVE COUNSEL AS PART
OF THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S.
PROFESSIONAL FELLOWS PROGRAM IS
FOR STEVE JUST PROGRAM BRINGS
LEADERS FROM AROUND THE WORLD TO
THE UNITED STATES TO BROADEN
THEIR PROFESSIONAL EXPERTISE.
NOW WE'RE GOING TO TRY THIS SO
NO PROMISES.
MISTER ALEXANDER MARANISS GIVEN
ME.
ANYBODY ELSE WANT TO TRY.
RIMINI SHOULD REALLY
[inaudible]
THE IS LEADING THE HE'S A
LEADING SPECIALIST IN THE LEGAL
ISSUES -- COMMITTEE WHICH IS A
WE IN PARLIAMENT IN GEORGIA IN
HIS CURRENT ROLE HE WORKS ON
DRAFTING BILLS AND ADAPTING
INTERNATIONAL LEGAL DOCUMENTS
FOR THE GEORGIAN WITH.
EXCUSE ME WITH GEORGE GEORGE IN
CONTEXT.
HERE WE GO AGAIN.
MISS ANNA [inaudible]
BLASKO LOOK.
THE LITTLE OKAY.
MADAM PRESIDENT LOST YOU.
THANK YOU ANNA BLAH SHOOT.
IS A LEGAL EXPERT IN THE OFFICE
OF NATIONAL INVESTMENT COUNSEL
TO THE REVIEW CRANE.
SEE WHAT.
THE TV CRANE SHE WORKS TO
ADVOCTE FOR IMPROVING UKRAINE'S
INVESTMENT CLIMATE THROUGH
LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS SHE ALSO
EXAMINES FOREIGN LAWS WITH AIM
AND I DID A FINE INTERNATIONAL
BEST PRACTICES.
I HOPE TO SEE THESE ACCOMPLISHED
INDIVIDUALS WILL BENEFIT GREATLY
FROM THEIR TIME ON HANDS ON
EXPERIENCE HERE IN OUR STATE
CAPITOL IN UNDER THE DIRECTION
OF MISS DIANE V<c.cyan> YOU'RE</c>
BUYING.
SO PLEASE COLLEAGUES WELCOME
THEM TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE
CAPITOL A WARM WELCOME
.
AND ANYONE WHO WISHES TO
PARTICIPATE IN A PHOTOGRAPH
LET'S TAKE.
ONE WITH THESE YOUNG FOLKS
.
THANK YOU AND NEXT UP WE HAVE
SENATOR ALAN.
SENATOR ALLEN AT THE PRO TEM'S
DESK THE FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
PRESIDENT I RISE TODAY TO
RECOGNIZE THE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
MUSIC. TO OUR GREAT STATE AND
MUSIC EDUCATION IN OUR SCHOOLS
AND IT'S MY VERY SPECIAL
PRIVILEGE TO INTRODUCE TO YOU --
MISS KIANA CONNELY AND MISTER
MICHAEL WINNER FROM THE
RECORDING ACADEMY -- KIANA IS
THE SECOND DIRECTOR OF THE
RECORDING ACADEMY'S LOS ANGELES
CHAPTER AND MICHAEL HEADS UP
THERE SAN FRANCISCO CHAPTER.
AND I JUST HAD A WONDERFUL
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM -- LAST
WEEK AT THEIR OFFICES IN SANTA
MONICA MY DISTRICT.
YOU MAY AND YOU MAY KNOW THAT
THE RECORDING ACADEMY WORKS ON
BEHALF OF REFORMERS SONG WRITERS
PRODUCERS ENGINEERS.
AND ALL MUSIC PROFESSIONALS TO
ENSURE THE RECORDING ARTS REMAIN
A THRIVING PART OF OUR SHARED
CULTURAL HERITAGE.
AND OUR CREATIVE ECONOMY.
AND MOST HI AM PROMINENCE THE
ACADEMY HONORS MUSIC'S HISTORY
THROUGH THE GRAMMY MUSEUM AND IT
CELEBRATES ARTISTIC EXCELLENCE.
THROUGH THE GRAMMY AWARDS.
BUT IN ADDITION TO THEIR WORK
WITH -- THE GRAMMY MUSEUM --
THEY'VE THEY DO YOUTH
PROGRAMMING THERE THEY HAVE AN
ACADEMY FOUNDATIONS THAT
SUPPORTS US INSOFAR AS FIRING.
MUSICIANS WITH THEIR GRAMMY IN
THE SCHOOLS PROGRAM.
AND CANNON MICHAEL ARE JOINING
US IN SACRAMENTO TO SHOW THEIR
SUPPORT OF OUR MUSIC EDUCATORS
ON STAND UP FOR MUSIC TODAY.
AS CENTER FOR MUSIC IS A
NONPROFIT COALITION OF DEDICATED
MUSIC TEACHERS IN MUSIC
EDUCATION SUPPORTERS WHO KNOW
FIRST HAND THAT MUSIC DELIVERS
IMPORTANT BENEFITS TO OUR
STUDENTS.
AND THAT THEY SHOULD THAT SHOULD
BE A A PART OF A COMPREHENSIVE.
EDUCATION I REALLY LOOKING
FORWARD TO SOME OF THE STING
PERFORMANCES THEIR SHOWCASE
TODAY.
IN THE CAPITAL SO I WANT TO I
WANT TO THANK THEM FOR BEING
HERE MEMBERS YOU KNOW WE CUT
BACK ON THE ARTS DURING TIMES OF
DOWNTURN.
AND IF YOU LOOK AT WHAT REALLY
CONNECTS. TO THOSE STUDENTS WHO
ARE MOST AFFECTED MOST
DISCONNECTED MOST LIKELY TO DROP
OUT.
IT'S OFTENTIMES A A HIGH QUALITY
ARTS EDUCATION IT CAN BRING THEM
BACK IN THAT CAN HELP THEM FEEL
SO THEY CAN BEGOOD IT'S THEY
CAN BE GOOD AT SCHOOL THEY'RE
CONNECTED TO SCHOOL.
IN A WHOLE DIFFERENT WAY IT
CONNECTS WITH STUDENTS IN A WAY
THAT SOMETIMES A TRADITIONAL
CURRICULUM DOESN'T.
THESE FOLKS ON THE RECORDING
ACADEMY IN SO MANY OF THEIR
COLLEAGUES ARE WORKING REALLY
HARD TO GET MUSIC BACK INTO OUR
SCHOOLS HIGH QUALITY MUSIC
INSTRUCTION IN OUR SCHOOLS FOR
KIDS.
AND I JUST WANNA GIVE THEM A
VERY VERY WARM WELCOME TODAY AND
WELCOME TO OUR SAY COUNTY
SENATOR ALLEN IN A VERY WARM
WELCOME TO OUR CVS.
REPRESENTING THE FINEST MUSIC.
RIGHT HERE IN CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
WHAT?
ARE THERE ANY OTHER PRIVILEGES
SOLVE THE FLOOR ANY OTHER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE MESSAGES.
SHE'S BEEN COLLEAGUES.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES.
WITHOUT OBJECTION THE SENATE
JOURNAL FOR MAY SIXTH THROUGH
MAY NINTH TWENTY NINETEEN WILL
BE APPROVED AS CORRECTED BY THE
MINUTE CLERK.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS AND NOTICES.
SEEING NONE WE WILL GO ON TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
SECOND READING FILE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE THIRTY FOUR AND
SENATE BILL THREE OH FIVE SECOND
READING FIRELESS STEAM BRED THE
SENATE THIRD READING FARO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
EXCUSE ME THIRD READING FILE.
A VERY GOOD ART COLLEAGUES WE'RE
GOING TO GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE UNDER THE SENATE THIRD
READING FILE FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE SENATOR PAN [inaudible]
PASS.
BY GIVE YOU MOMENT HERE LET'S.
LET'S TRY TO BE PREPARED AS WE
GO THROUGH THE FILE.
WE'LL START WITH FILE ITEM
NUMBER.
NINE COLLEAGUES IF YOU'D GET TO
YOUR DESTINATION OF WE COULD
HAVE SOME QUIET IN THE IN THE
HALL.
QUITE ON THE FLOOR PLEASE FOR
SENATOR PAN MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL TWO NINETY SEVEN BY
SENATOR PAN AND ACT RULING
SCHOOL FACILITIES.
SENATOR PAM THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT SENATORS -- FOR
DECADES SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
STRUGGLE TO MEET THIS SUMMER
CONSTRUCTION DEADLINES AHEAD
STUDENTS ARRIVING FOR CLASSES IN
THE FALL OFTEN RESULTING EDITION
ACOSTA LAYS IN THIS PLACE
STUDENTS.
THE FIRST WEEKS OR EVEN MONTHS
OF CONTRACT ACTIVITY UNDER A
NEWLY AWARDED CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTOR FOCUSED ON
PRELIMINARY WORK OF AWARDING
SUBCONTRACTS MAKING SHOP
DRAWINGS.
IN ORDER IN MATERIALS THE
AUTHORITY TO AWARD CONSTRUCTION
CONTRACTS PRIOR TO SEE ARCHITECT
APPROVAL CURRENTLY EXIST FOR
DESIGN BUILD PROJECTS.
AND FOR K. THROUGH TWELVE LEASE
LEASEBACK PROJECTS BUT NOT FOR
TRADITIONALLY COMPETITIVELY BID
PROJECTS SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
WILL ALLOW SCHOOLS AND COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS TO WORK CON.
CONSTRUCTION CONTRACTS BUT NOT
PERFORM CONSTRUCTION PRIOR TO
RECEIVING PLAN APPROVAL FROM THE
STATE ARCHITECT THAT
STREAMLINING SUMMER CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS SB TWO NINETY SEVEN
ALSO ALLOW SCHOOL DISTRICT AVOID
COSTLY DELAYS FOR MAINTAINING
STUDENT SAFETY.
HAS PROVIDED BY THE FIELD ACT.
SB TWO NINE SEVEN IS SUPPORTED
BY SCHOOL FACILITY PROFESSIONALS
AND CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES ARE
ACTUALLY CODIFIED A LEGISLATIVE
RECOMMENDATIONS MADE BY TASK
FORCE COMMISSION BY THE DIVISION
OF STATE ARCHITECT.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN I VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THE ITEM
IS ARE ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
ON FILE ITEM NUMBER.
NINE SEEING NONE MISTER
ALLEN.
HI ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
I CARRY IT ALL [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
JANE [inaudible]
BY DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
BY GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
BY WITH SO.
HI -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON BY JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I'M.
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
I MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK.
I'M A REAL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH AYE RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
OUR CASKEY.
I WIENER.
AYE WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
SENATOR PAN MOVES A CALL.
FILE ITEM.
TEN SENATOR LABOR.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE ONE BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACCOLADE MEDI CAL.
SENATOR LABOR THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING MEMBERS FOR MANY YEARS
CALIFORNIA HAS MADE A CONCERTED
EFFORT TO EXPAND AND PROTECT.
QUALITY FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
BUT RECENT CHANGES IN THE
FEDERAL POLICIES JEOPARDIZE
ACCESS TO THOSE CRITICAL
SERVICES.
PART OF THAT COMMITMENT IS
FAMILY PACKED WHICH IS A
MEDICAID PROGRAMS ADMINISTERED
BY THE DEPARTMENT OF HEALTH CARE
SERVICES.
FAMILY BACK SERVICES INCLUDE ALL
FDA APPROVED CONTRACEPTIVE
METHODS METHODS ARE MERGING SEE
CONTRACEPTIVES TESTING AND
TREATMENT OF SEXUALLY
TRANSMITTED INFECTIONS AND
URINARY TRACT INFECTIONS ALONG
WITH SCREENING FOR BREAST AND
CERVICAL CANCER.
CURRENTLY FAMILY PACK IS FUNDED
BY A NINETY TEN FEDERAL MATCH
MEANING THAT FOR EVERY ONE
DOLLAR INVESTED IN FAMILY
PLANNING CARE THE STATE RECEIVES
NINETY CENTS FROM THE FEDERAL
GOVERNMENT.
OVER THE PAST TWO YEARS FEDERAL
PROPOSALS OF CALL FOR SHIFTING
ALL FEDERAL MEDICAID FUNDS TO
STATES IN A BLOCK GRANT FORM.
WITHOUT A PLAN IN PLACE ACCESS
TO FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES FOR
LOW INCOME AN UNINSURED
CALIFORNIANS COULD BE DISRUPTED
AND SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCED SB
THREE ONE PROVIDES A FRAMEWORK
FOR THAT PLAN.
IN THE EVENT OF REDUCTIONS IN
FEDERAL FUNDING SB THRILL ONE
REQUIRED DH CS TO SUBMIT A PLAN
TO THE LEGISLATURE.
WITHIN SIXTY DAYS OF ANY FEDERAL
ACTION MEMBERS AS WE ALL KNOW
THE FEDERAL LANDSCAPE CHANGES
FROM DAY TO DAY SO IT IS
IMPORTANT THE CALIFORNIA STAND
READY.
IN CASE FAMILY PLANNING SERVICES
IN OUR STATE ARE THREATENED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM AND I WOULD REQUEST PLEASE
THE NOISE IN THE BACK.
PLEASE KEEP THE NOISE DOWN AND
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS TO THE
BACK OF THE ROOM PLEASE SO WE
CAN HEAR THE PRESENTATIONS BY
OUR COLLEAGUES.
ANY DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
BATES.
HI BILL.
I PORCHES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
HI KELLY AT ALL.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
BY DODD.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROWTH
[inaudible]
BY.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
BY LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONEY BY MORE LARK.
I AM A REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
I PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROSS.
I RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
OUR COUNTY BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudble]
ATKINS [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
SENATOR LABOR MOVES TO CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM ELEVEN
FILE ITEM ELEVEN CENTER CUBBY
ERROL MISTER SECRETARY PEASE
READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE TWENTY SEVEN BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AND ACT RELATES
LOCAL GOVERNMENT.
SENATOR CAFIERO THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FIVE TWENTY SEVEN A MEASURE THAT
WOULD ALLOW CANNABIS AND
INDUSTRIAL HEMP CULTIVATORS TO
RECEIVE THE PER THE SAME
PROPERTY TAX ASSESSMENT AND
RELIEF.
AS OTHER AGRICULTURAL SECTORS IN
THE STATE BY OPERATING THEM INTO
THE WILLIAMSON ACT.
THE CALIFORNIA LAND CONSERVATION
ACT OF NINETEEN SIXTY FIVE ALSO
KNOWN AS THE WILLIAMSON ACT
ESTABLISHES AT THE STOP WISHED
MEANS OF PROTECTING AGRICULTURAL
AND OPEN SPACE LAND.
BY REDUCING THE BURDENS IMPOSED
BY RISING PROPERTY TAX RATES.
THE ACT ALLOWS PRIVATE
LANDOWNERS TO ENTER INTO A
CONTRACT CONTRACTUAL AGREEMENT
WITH LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO
VOLUNTARILY RESTRICT THEIR LAND
TO AGRICULTURAL AND COMPATIBLE
OPEN SPACE USES.
THE RESULT THIS RESULTS IN
SUBSTANTIALLY REDUCED PROPERTY
TAX ASSESSMENTS WHICH ARE BASED
UPON INCOME GENERATED RATHER
THAN POTENTIAL MARKET VALUE OF
THE PROPERTY.
IT'S IT'S CRITICAL THAT WE
INCLUDE CANNABIS CULTIVATORS
WITHIN THE WILLIAMSON ACT SO
THEY CAN RECEIVE THE SAME.
TAX ASSESSMENTS THAT AS OTHER
AGRICULTURAL PRODUCTS LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AT THEIR DISCRETION
ARE ABLE TO DETERMINE WHICH AG
PRODUCTS ARE DEEMED ELIGIBLE FOR
THE FOR THE WILLIAMS ENACT TAX
SAVINGS.
AND IT'S ESTIMATED THAT THIS ACT
SAVE AGRICULTURAL LANDOWNERS
ANYWHERE FROM 2275% AND PROPERTY
TAX LIABILITY EACH YEAR.
IT'S A SMALL BUT IMPORTANT STEP
IN ACHIEVING EQUALITY IN THE
BILL HAS NO OPPOSITION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECTOR PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARE SO THAT A I ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
I CAN BE AT ALL [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
HI DODD.
I DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
AYE GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI -- TITLE [inaudible]
NO.
JACKSON NO NO JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
HI RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
STERN -- I STONE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NUMBER.
I WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI YEAH.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
YES [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN.
BY SKINNER BY.
SENATOR CAFIERO MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTEEN
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SENATOR STERN
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR STERN AN ACT RELATING TO
THE ARTS.
SENATOR STERN THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT -- MEMBERS SB SEVEN
FORTY TO SUPPORT SUPPORT AND WHY
SHOULD IT BE.
THE USE OF THE STATE.
NEED A POET VOICE.
ALONG SIDE.
WHAT WE HAVE FOR ADULTS THE NEXT
GENERATION?
HAS CREATIVITY IN ITS POWER AND
I JUST WANT TO QUOTE WHEN DILLON
BROOKS.
BY SAYING.
I SHALL CREATE.
IF NOT A WHOLE.
I KNOW.
IF NOT AN OVERTURE A DESECRATION
IF WE DON'T GIVE YOUNG PEOPLE AN
OPPORTUNITY CREATIVE.
THEY'LL HAVE NO OTHER OUTLET
WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATOR STERN DEBATER
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I HARSH LETTER.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL [inaudible]
I PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
WORDS I COPYRIGHT [inaudible]
CHANGE [inaudible]
BY DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
I GROWTH [inaudible]
BY HERTZBERG.
I HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
I JACKSON BY JONES.
HI LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MORNING.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
I'M REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
BY ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
BY COUNTY.
BY WINNER BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
BY.
A SENATORS STERN MOVES A CALL
FILE ITEM.
EIGHTEEN SENATOR DODD YOU
PREPARED TO TAKE UP THE SIDE OF
MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE READ FILE ITEM EIGHTEEN
SENATE BILL THREE THIRTY SIX BY
SENATOR DODD AN ACTOR LINDA
TRANSPORTATION SENATOR DODD.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SB THREE THREE SIX
REQUIRES THE PRESENCE OF AT
LEAST ONE PUBLIC TRANSIT
EMPLOYEE.
ON FULLY AUTONOMOUS -- TRANSIT
VEHICLES.
FULLY AUTOMATED VEHICLES CREATE
OPPORTUNITIES TO IMPROVE PUBLIC
TRANSIT BUT THEY POSE RISKS AS
WELL.
A TRANSIT A BOY NOT ONLY
ENHANCES THE PUBLIC SAFETY IN
EMERGENCIES BUT ALSO SUPPORTS
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
AND ELDERLY IN THE EVENT THAT
THEY NEED ASSISTANCE UTILIZING.
BOARDING IN SECURING WHEELCHAIRS
FURTHER TRANSIT EMPLOYEES OFFER
INFORMATION ABOUT ROUTES
DIRECTIONS FOR PASSENGERS OR
IDENTIFY WHERE ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT THE TRANSIT
SERVICE CAN BE FOUND.
WITHOUT A HUMAN ON BOARD PUBLIC
TRANSIT AGENCIES AND VEHICLES
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS CAN BE
LEFT OUT OF THE TECHNOLOGICAL
ADVANCES IN THE TRANSPORTATION
INDUSTRY.
ADDITIONALLY OVER MILLION
DRIVERS TRANSPORT PASSENGERS FOR
A LIVING.
PUBLIC TRANSIT JOBS ARE STABLE
JOBS AT GOOD WAGES AND BENEFITS
FULLY AUTONOMOUS PUBLIC TRANSIT --
DISPLACES WORKERS WITHOUT ANY
PLAN TO RETRAIN THEM.
UNTIL IT TAUGHT IN A STRIP
TECHNOLOGY BECOMES MORE CAPABLE
AND TACTICAL LOGICAL GLITCHES
ARE WORKED THROUGH.
INCLUDING A PUBLIC TRANSIT
EMPLOYEE ON AND THOMAS VEHICLES
WILL ENSURE VULNERABLE
POPULATIONS ARE NOT MARGINALIZE
[inaudible]
UP.
I'M I'M AWARE THAT SOME MEMBERS
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
POTENTIAL IMPACTS OF THIS BILL
ON THE FIRST OR LAST MILE IF A
PRIVATE COMPANY CONTRACTS WITH
THE PUBLIC TRANSIT OPERATOR.
IN I COMMIT TO WORKING TO
ADDRESS THESE CONCERNS AS THE
BILL MOVES FORWARD INTERESTINGLY
ENOUGH THIS WAS NOT BROUGHT UP
BUT YOU KNOW IN TILL JUST
RECENTLY SO I AM LOOKING FORWARD
TO WORKING ON THAT ISSUE ISSUE
IS THIS -- MOVES THROUGH
RESPECTFULLY AFTER I'VE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SENATOR GLAZER.
MADAM PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS -- I
REGRETTABLY RISE IN OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL -- TODAY SHOT.
FIRST I WANT TO THANK OF MY
COLLEAGUE THE SENATOR FROM NAPA.
FOR RAISING A VERY IMPORTANT
ISSUE -- WHICH IS THE
DESTRUCTION THAT THIS TECHNOLOGY.
IS DOING TO MANY PEOPLE WHO HAVE
EMPLOYMENT IN THIS FIELD.
I THERE'S NOBODY ON THIS FLOOR
WAS A BIGGER HEART -- THAN THE
SENATOR FROM NAPA FOR THE THAT
THE IMPACT THAT THAT TECHNOLOGY
IS HAVING IN HIS BILL REFLECTS
THAT CONCERN THAT.
HE RIGHTFULLY HAS.
YEAH.
THIS ISSUE OF FIVE HOW
INNOVATION AND TECHNOLOGY IS
COMING INTO OUR WORLD AND THE
DESTRUCTION IT CAUSES.
IS A CRITICAL ONE FOR US AS
LEADERS OF THE SENATE AS LEADERS
IN THE STATE.
I IN FACT A COLLEAGUE OF OURS
FROM VENTURA HAS A HAS
LEGISLATION.
THAT PROMOTES A TASK FORCE ABOUT
THE FUTURE OF WORK.
WHICH GOES TO THE HEART OF WHAT
THIS BILL IS TRYING TO SOLVE.
BUT FOR ME.
THE ANSWER IS TO NOT.
SIGN ME OR STOP TECHNOLOGY
INNOVATION.
THE ANSWER IT LIES IN EDUCATION.
TRAINING AND RETRAINING.
THAT THE DISRUPTION THAT'S GOING
TO BE CAUSED BY.
THE THE INNOVATIONS.
OF AUTONOMY AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES
AND MANY OTHER THINGS IN OUR
WORLD.
ARE NOT ARE NOT SOLVED.
ARE NOT SOLVED BY.
PUTTING OUR HEAD IN THE SAND AND
SAYING.
IT SHOULDN'T HAPPEN.
ARE WE SHOULD PUT BARRIERS TO
MAKING THAT HAPPEN.
LOOK AT THE LOOK AT THE GOALS OF
THE TIMES FEELS WHAT ARE WHAT
ARE THEY IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO
LOWER COSTS.
IT'S AN ATTEMPT TO IMPROVE
SAFETY.
IT'S AN EFFORT TO PROMOTE
TRANSIT.
IF WE CAN GET PEOPLE FROM THEIR
HOUSES OR THEIR APARTMENTS TO
TRANSIT IN A MORE EFFICIENT
EFFECTIVE WAY WE'RE GOING TO
PROMOTE.
OUR TRANSIT SYSTEMS THAT ARE SO
IMPORTANT TO OUR FUTURE.
THEY'RE MEANT TO THAT IT BE DONE
AN ENVIRONMENTALLY FRIENDLY WAY.
THESE A THOMAS VEHICLES ARE
PRINCIPALLY ELECTRIC VEHICLES.
AND THE TECHNOLOGY THAT'S GOING
INTO THESE THE PROMOTION OF
THESE VEHICLES.
HELP CALIFORNIA BECOME A LEADER
IN THE WORLD -- IN IN
MANUFACTURING I IN THE ARE IN DE
IN THIS WHOLE SPACE WHY WOULD WE
WANT TO SIGN ME -- THAT WORK.
IS THE TIME OF HIS VEHICLES ARE
NOT SOME.
ODD.
THING THAT'S FAR INTO THE
DISTANCE.
THESE A THOMAS VEHICLES TRANSIT
VEHICLES ARE BEING TESTED NOW
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA
[inaudible]
ON STREETS.
ON OUR PROPERTY I KNOW IN MY
DISTRICT BOTH AND NOT SAN RAMON
AND IN DUBLIN.
THESE ECONOMIST VEHICLES ARE
BEING TESTED IN MANY THINK ABOUT
WHAT ARE THEY I IN THIS CASE
THERE TWELVE PASSENGER VEHICLES
ARE NOT GIANT BUSES -- YES SIX
SEATS IN SIX PLACES WHERE YOU
CAN STAND -- AND WHILE WE MAY
THINK THAT THIS LEGISLATION IS
ONLY ABOUT GIANT BUS SYSTEMS ARE
GIANT BUSES WE DON'T KNOW WHERE
THAT TECHNOLOGY IS GOING TO LEAD
IN THE FUTURE IS IT GOING TO BE
SIX PASSENGER. TWELVE PASSENGER
TWENTY PASSENGER.
WHERE IS THIS ISSUE POTS STOP IN
TERMS OF HAVING AT A TRANSIT
EMPLOYEE ON EVERY EVERYONE OF
THEM?
SO.
IT IS TRUE THAT TECHNOLOGY IS
DISRUPTIVE.
BUT THINK ABOUT IT -- WOULD WE
SAY WE WANT TO DEFEND THE HORSE
AND BUGGY WOULD WE WANT TO SAY
WE WANT TO DEFEND THE TYPEWRITER.
THESE THINGS ON ALL OUR DESKS.
THE IN THESE THIS IS ANOTHER
FORM OF DISRUPTION OF TECHNOLOGY
FOR ALL THE PEOPLE THAT WE MIGHT
HAVE RELIED UPON TO WRITE MEMOS
AND LETTERS AND ALL THE REST OF
THE THINGS THAT WE AT WEEK WE
COUNT ON IN OUR WORK WORLD.
SO I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS THAT
A COMMITMENT TO WORK ON THIS
LAST MILE ISSUE.
BUT I THINK THAT THE ANSWER TO
THIS I IN THIS LEGISLATION ON
THIS AREA AND THROUGHOUT STATE
GOVERNMENT IS TO NOT PUT OUR
HEAD IN THE SAND THE ANSWER FOR
US IS THE LEAD.
ON EDUCATION ON TRAINING AND
RETRAINING I THINK THAT'S THE
BETTER SOLUTION AND WHY CAN'T
SUPPORT THE BILL TODAY
[inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH BYE TO
PRESENT ALL THE SUPPORTING --
THE BILL TODAY -- I DO HAVE.
SIMILAR CONCERNS TO THOSE
EXPRESSED -- BY THE SENATOR.
FROM AROUND -- ABOUT -- WE NEED
TO BE CAUTIOUS ABOUT
TECHNOLOGICAL -- CHANGES AND NOT
TO REACH FOR OUT INTO THE FUTURE
IN PARTICULAR -- WHEN WE DON'T
KNOW WHAT THE FUTURE'S GOING TO
HOLD ON THE -- I AM HOWEVER
COMFORTABLE SUPPORTING THE BILL
TODAY -- BECAUSE IT DOES SUNSET
AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE AND THE
REALITY IS THAT IT'S GOING TO
TAKE BEFORE WE GET TO A POINT.
WHERE WE HAVE TRULY AUTONOMOUS?
VEHICLES WITHOUT ANYONE IN THEM
OPERATING -- AS PART OF OUR
GENERAL TRANSPORTATION SYSTEM
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT'S
GOING TO BE HAPPENING IN THE
IMMEDIATE FUTURE I'M COMFORTABLE
SUPPORTING THIS WITH THE TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE SUNSET -- BUT I DO
JUST WANT TO NOTE THAT I DO ALSO
HAVE THOSE QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR GALGIANI.
I RISE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL I
THINK IT'S A MODEST --
REQUIREMENT A IN OTHER COUNTRIES
WHERE THEY HAVE HIGH SPEED RAIL
AND HIGHER SPEED RAIL THEY HAVE
POSITIVE TRAIN CONTROL THAT
ALLOWS A TRAIN TO SLOW
AUTOMATICALLY WHEN IT'S GOING
AROUND A CURVE -- FOR IT HAS THE
POSITIVE TRAIN CONTROL FOR WHEN
THERE'S A NEED FOR EARTHQUAKE
DETECTION.
AND THE LIKE BUT THEY ALWAYS
HAVE SOMEBODY ON BOARD A LIVE
PERSON WE KNOW THAT WE'VE HAD
SAFETY ISSUES WITH PASSENGERS
BOARDING -- PASSENGER RAIL AND
POSING A THREAT TO WHETHER
PASSENGERS THAT IS ALSO A REASON
WHY WE HAVE A NEED TO HAVE
SOMEBODY ON BOARD.
AND THEN FINALLY FOR ANY MEDICAL
EMERGENCY I WAS AT A PEACE
OFFICERS MEMORIAL EVENT
YESTERDAY AND WE HAD ONE PERSON
IN ATTENDANCE WHO PASSED OUT AND
BECAUSE OTHER PEOPLE WERE AROUND.
A MEDICAL PERSONNEL WILL BE ABLE
TO BE ON THE SPOT RIGHT AWAY SO
I APPRECIATE THE AUTHORS THAT
WILLINGNESS TO WORK ON THAT LAST
ISSUE BUT I STRONGLY RECOMMEND
AN AYE VOTE ON THIS BILL.
SENATOR STERN FALL BY SENATOR
MORE LOCK.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
BEEN WORKING ON THIS ISSUE
AROUND AUTOMATION THE FUTURE OF
WORK FOR A FEW YEARS NOW THE
GOVERNOR RECENTLY -- ANNOUNCED A
FUTURE OF WORK COMMISSION IN
FACT -- THE LAST WEEK ON
INTERNATIONAL WORKERS DAY.
AND ALL ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
ACTUALLY RIGHT NOW RIDE SHARING
DRIVERS ARE STRIKING.
TRYING TO FIND A BETTER WAY TO
SYSTEM AND OPPORTUNITIES IN AN
INCREASINGLY AUTOMATED IN
NETWORK FUTURE [inaudible]
THERE ARE.
CHALLENGES WITH THIS LEGISLATION
THE MECHANICS I THINK YOU NEED
WORK.
I STILL BELIEVE THAT THE
COLLECTIVE BARGAINING PROCESS IS
AN IMPORTANT WAY.
TO A CERTAIN ONESELF AND FINE
MECHANICS THAT ARE TAILORED TO
THE NATURE OF THIS KIND OF
TRANSIT SERVICE AND NOT
ARBITRARILY PUSHING OUT.
OTHER AUTOMATED VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGIES BUT THAT SAID I
THINK.
ON BALANCE WE HAVE TO STAND WITH
THE WORKING PEOPLE OF THIS STATE.
AND PUT PEOPLE FIRST AND THAT'S
WHY I'M UP IN SUPPORT TODAY.
AS WELL AS WITH.
THOSE STRIKING AND OTHERS OUT
THERE SEEKING SOME KIND OF
BETTER WAGE IN THE FUTURE.
THIS IS COMPLICATED THIS NEEDS
WORK WE LOOK FORWARD TO SEEING
IT COME BACK -- IN IN IMPROVE
CONDITION BUT I THINK IT
DESERVES OUR SUPPORT TODAY THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU SENATOR MORLOCK THANK
YOU MADAM PRESIDENT IT IS GOOD
TO HAVE A GOOD DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR TODAY -- DRIVERLESS
TECHNOLOGY ECONOMIST VEHICLES
THIS IS THE FUTURE THIS IS.
A TOPIC WE SHOULD REALLY BE
HAVING A LOT OF FUN WITH -- SO
SOMEONE WANTS TO USE A
DRIVERLESS [inaudible]
BUS.
BUT THEY NEED DIRECTIONS SERVER
ASSISTANCE ABOUT THE CITY OR
TOWN YOU'RE IN.
THAT'S WHY WE HAVE IPHONES YOU
JUST.
GET IN AND GET YOUR INFORMATION
IF YOU NEED HELP WITH THE
DISABILITY WELL THEN THE TRANSIT
AGENCIES SHOULD BE PROVIDING
VEHICLES FOR THOSE THAT HAVE.
PHYSICAL NEEDS THEY DON'T EVEN
HAVE EVERYBODY IS DESIGNED FOR
YOU COULD ORDER A DISABILITY VAN.
AND IT WOULD COME DIRECTLY TO
YOU TAKE YOU WHERE YOU NEED TO
GO.
SO I THINK WE NEED TO GET AHEAD
OF THE TECHNOLOGY NOT CLING TO
THE STATUS QUO.
THIS IS CALIFORNIA.
WE'VE GOT TO EMBRACE THE FUTURE
WE SHOULD BUILD ROADS AND
COMPUTER INTERFACES TO PROMOTE
THE TECHNOLOGY.
THE ECONOMY IS GREAT
UNEMPLOYMENT IS AT THE LOWEST
IT'S BEEN HISTORICALLY A FOR
LIKE SIXTY YEARS THERE ARE JOBS
AVAILABLE. FOR COLLEAGUES I ATE
I THINK WE SHOULDN'T BE HAS WE
SHOULD NOT BE HESITANT WE SHOULD
BE MOVING FORWARD.
LET'S NOT PUT THE BRAKES ON THE
FUTURE I URGE A NO VOTE ON
SENATE BILL THREE THREE SIX
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I JUST
WANTED TO RISE TO OFFER -- THE
VERY BRIEF COMMENTS BECAUSE I
KNOW A LOT HAS BEEN SAID ON THIS
BILL BUT YOU KNOW WHEN WHEN THE
AUTOMOBILE REPLACE THE BUGGY IT
IT WAS A NOT AN ADONIS VEHICLE
THAT HAD A HUMAN BEING OPERATING
AT AND IN OUREVERYWHERE WE HAVE
INTRODUCED.
AUTOMATION WE HAVE PEOPLE A
COMPANY THAT AUTOMATION IF YOU
GO TO A IF YOU GO TO A
MANUFACTURER IDLE MANUFACTURING
PLANT YOU'LL SEE.
PEOPLE OVERSEEING THE AUTOMATION.
THIS IS JUSTIN MANUFACTURING
LESIONS ON MOBILE WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT TRANSPORTATION WHERE WE
HAVE AN OBLIGATION THE
GOVERNMENT HAS AN OBLIGATION TO
PROVIDE FOR THE PUBLIX.
HEALTH AND SAFETY IN THESE
PROCESSES IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT
GETTING.
TRANSPORTING YOURSELF FROM POINT
A TO POINT B..
BUT DOING IT SAFELY AND IT'S NOT
JUST ABOUT LOOKING FOR A
LOCATION.
IT'S ABOUT HAVING ALL THE
SYSTEMS IN PLACE TO ENSURE THAT
PEOPLE ARE SAFE IN THAT PROCESS.
THE TECHNOLOGY IS NOT THERE YET
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THIS IS A
VERY MODEST BILL THIS IS A VERY
REASONABLE BILL.
AS IT EVOLVES.
IN THE MEANTIME WE'RE GONNA NEED.
A HUMAN ELEMENT TO BE PART OF
THIS PROCESS WITH.
RIGHT CURRENTLY AS AUTONOMOUS
TECHNOLOGY IS BEING DEVELOPED --
ARE LOSING THEIR LIVES IN THIS
PROCESS OUT THERE.
WE CAN'T RISK THIS AND IT'S NOT
ABOUT STIFLING INNOVATION
BECAUSE EVEN WITH -- VEHICLES
THAT ARE CURRENTLY BEING DRIVEN
BY PEOPLE IT'S NOT STOPPING THIS
TECHNOLOGY FROM MOVING FORWARD
IT'S NOT STOPPING INVESTMENT IN
THOSE AREAS FROM TAKING PLACE
IT'S NOT STOPPING [inaudible]
ADVANCEMENTS IN IN IN THIS AREA
I THINK IT'S LUDICROUS TO MAKE
THOSE ARGUMENTS THIS BILL DOES
NOT DO THAT IT'S SIMPLY
[inaudible]
INSURERS.
THAT WE WILL BE THERE.
IT ENSURING THE PEOPLE.
ARE SAFE WHEN THEY'RE UTILIZING
THIS TECHNOLOGY AND THEY'RE SAFE
WHEN THEY'RE BEING TRANSPORTED.
THIS IS ALL ABOUT PUBLIC SAFETY
THIS IS A VERY MODEST BILL I
THINK.
THIS DEBATE IS GREATLY
EXAGGERATING WHAT THIS BILL WILL
DO I HOPE EVERYBODY CAN SUPPORT
IT I THINK IT'S JUST US DOING
OUR JOBS AND WE'LL ALL THAT TO
THE PEOPLE OF THE STATE.
THANK YOU SENATOR HUESO SEEING
NO FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR DODD YOU MAY CLOSE.
MADAM PRESIDENT -- PERSONAL I DO --
I APPRECIATE THE DEBATE ON THIS
BILL I THINK FOR MY COLLEAGUES
GOOD COLLEAGUES FROM A RENDON
COSTA MESA I APPRECIATE.
YOUR CONCERNS -- YET LOOK AT
NOBODY IN THIS ROOM WATCHES
STYMIE INNOVATION -- AND NOBODY
WANTS TO HAVE THEIR HAD TO SAY
AND I THINK THIS LEGISLATION --
HELP SO THAT -- IS IT IN THE
FUTURE WE HAVE OPERATORS A DON'T
HAVE THEIR HEAD IN THE SAND THAT
THEY UNDERSTAND THAT THIS
LEGISLATURE -- WANTS TO MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE CUSTOMER
SERVICE -- FOR OF YOUR PEOPLE
THAT ARE IN IN WHEELCHAIRS AND
PEOPLE THAT IT SENIOR CITIZENS
AND WE BEEN ON SENATE TRIPS WERE.
THAT THESE TYPE OF THINGS THAT
HAPPENED ON THE TOP OF HIS
VEHICLES -- THAT REALLY HELPED
US WERE IN PARTICULAR WERE
LANGUAGE IS A BARRIER -- AS WELL
SO -- I COMMIT -- TO THOSE THAT
HAD CONCERNS MY GOOD COLLEAGUE
FROM SAM'S DISCO -- BROUGHT THAT
UP ABOUT SOME OF THESE AREAS
THESE WILL BE -- IN AREAS THAT --
WE WILL BE LOOKING AT AND I'M
SURE YOU'LL HAVE SOMETHING
BEFORE YOU -- YOU KNOW SOON IN
CONCURRENCE THAT -- WILL HELP --
YOU WITH THIS VOTE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOT ALL DEBATE
HAVING SEIZED MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
HI PORGES [inaudible]
BRADFORD.
BY CARRIER -- CHANGE
[inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
HI GALGIANI [inaudible]
I GLAZER [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
NO HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HILL.
BY HUESO.
BY -- TITLE BY JACKSON HI BY
JONES.
NO.
LEYVA.
BUY MCGUIRE BY MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LAW.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
BY Y. CASKEY.
BY WINNER BY WILK [inaudible]
HI.
HE'S CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
BATES.
OR GORGEOUS -- HI [inaudible]
CABALLERO [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
PAN.
I IS TWENTY FIVE NO SEVEN THE
MEASURE PASSES COLLEAGUES WE
GONNA GO BACK BRIEFLY TO
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR FOR
SENATOR BATES SENATOR BATES
FLOORS YOURS.
YOU THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENTE I
AM PLEASED TO INTRODUCE IN THE
GALLERY THIS MORNING JOINING US
FOR MISSION HILLS CHRISTIAN
SCHOOL IN MY DISTRICT RANCHO
SANTA MARGARITA.
OUR MISSION HILLS CHRISTIAN
SCHOOL. TO SEND THEIR TEACHER
FOURTH GRADE TEACHER ALEX DOMINO
PLEASE RECOGNIZE THEM AND I
BELIEVE THE RIGHT UP THERE.
A WARM WELCOME TO OUR STUDENTS
FROM THE MISSION HILLS CHRISTIAN
SCHOOL.
WELCOME TO THE STATE SENATE.
ALL RIGHT A COLLEAGUES GOING
BACK TO THE DAILY FILE SENATOR
LEYVA FILE ITEM NINETEEN WERE ON
FILE ITEM NINETEEN MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL TWO TWENTY SEVEN BY SENATOR
LEYVA AN ACT RULING TO HEALTH
AND CARE FACILITIES SENATOR
LABOR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING AGAIN MEMBERS AS MANY OF
YOU REMEMBER YOU SLICE SIMILAR
VERSION OF THIS BILL LAST YEAR
SB TWELVE EIGHTY EIGHT WHICH WAS
UNFORTUNATELY BE TELL BY THE
GOVERNOR.
THE FORMER GOVERNOR NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS ARE CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT FOR BOTH THE COUNTLESS
PATIENTS WHO SEE KEREN HOSPITALS
AS WELL AS THE NURSES WHO WORK
HERE IN CALIFORNIA.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN EMPOWERS THE
CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC
HEALTH CV PH TO ENSURE PATIENT
SAFETY -- SAFETY BY FORCING
MANDATED LONGSTANDING NURSE TO
PATIENT RATIOS AND FINING
HOSPITALS THAT REPEATEDLY BREAK
THE STANDARDS.
FROM 200-082-2000 SEVENTEEN
THERE WERE A TOTAL OF SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR OUT OF
RATIO DEFICIENCY ALLEGATIONS
REPORTED TO CBT CV PH. SIX
HUNDRED AND THIRTY FOUR TIMES
THERE WERE NOT ENOUGH NURSES TO
CARE FOR PATIENTS.
UNFORTUNATELY THE DEPARTMENTS
PRESENT ENFORCEMENT MEASURES ARE
SIMPLY NOT ENOUGH CURRENTLY THE
DEPARTMENT CONDUCTS SURVEYS
EVERY THREE YEARS TO ENSURE THE
HOSPITALS ARE COMPLYING WITH THE
LAW.
THIS PERIODIC CHECK IS FAR TOO
INFREQUENT ALLOWS HOSPITALS TO
PREPARE.
CD PH OFFICIALS BEFORE THEY
CONDUCT THEIR SURVEY.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN WOULD ADDRESS
THIS PROBLEM BY REQUIRING THAT
THE DEPARTMENT CONDUCT
UNANNOUNCED VISITS TO INSPECT
FOR COMPLIANCE WITH NURSE
STAFFING REQUIREMENTS.
THIS MEASURE WOULD ALSO EMPOWER
THE DEPARTMENT TO ENFORCE THE
STAFFING REQUIREMENT.
WITH FINES IN CASES WHERE THOSE
RATIOS HAVE BEEN VIOLATED.
MEMBERS I KNOW THAT SOME OF YOU
HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT HOSPITALS
RECEIVING FINES WHEN A NURSE
CALLS OUT SICK OR HAVING A
MERCHANT SEES THAT REQUIRE THEM
TO UNEXPECTEDLY LEAVE WORK.
IN RESPONSE TO THIS I WOULD SAY.
IF HOSPITALS ARE CONTINUALLY
STAFFING.
LEVELS WERE FROM ONE OR TWO
NURSES CALL OUT SICK PUTS THEM
AT RISK OF BEING OUT OF RATIO.
THEN THIS IS A SYSTEMATIC
PROBLEM THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED.
SECONDLY IT IS NEVER BEEN MY
INTENT TO PUNISH HOSPITALS THAT
ARE GOOD ACTORS AND I'M
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THIS
ISSUE AND POLICY COMMITTEE IN
THE ASSEMBLY OR WE CAN HAVE A
MORE ROBUST STAKEHOLDER
CONVERSATION.
SB TWO TWO SEVEN IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT SO THAT WE CAN PROTECT
PATIENT HEALTH AND SAFETY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR STONE.
THANK YOU BETTER PRESIDENT AND I
CERTAINLY UPON THE AUTHORS --
ATTEMPT TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
PROPER NURSING COVERAGE IN OUR
HOSPITALS BUT AS SHE MENTIONS --
INNER FOR SPEECH.
TO HUNT FOR SEEN.
ISSUES THAT COME UP WITH --
PEOPLE SHOWING UP LATE TO KNOW
WE DO HAVE SOME TRAFFIC ISSUES
IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA THAT
SB ONE IS SUPPOSED TO BE SOLVING
THAT HASN'T SOLVED YET.
AND PEOPLE DO GET SICK AND TWO
PEOPLE HAVE. SIX CHILDREN AND
THESE BONDS ARE VERY PUNITIVE I
MEAN FOR THE FIRST OFFENSE
THIRTY THOUSAND DOLLARS. SIXTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS FOR THE SECOND --
VIOLATION -- I DON'T THINK A
HOSPITAL ADMINISTRATORS WAKE UP
IN THE MORNING AND SAY YOU KNOW
I'M GONNA TRY TO PULL BACK AS
MANY NURSES I POSSIBLY PLANNED
OCCURS THE BOTTOM LINE OF OUR
HOSPITALS.
WHAT WE'VE SEEN IN THE WAY OF --
HEALTH CARE RATES AND AND
HOSPITAL STAYS I MEAN THEY'RE
GOING UP DRAMATICALLY YOU THINK
THESE FINES ARE JUST GONNA HURT
THE HOSPITAL THE NEXT COULD HURT
THE HOSPITAL TO BE PASSED ON TO
THE CONSUMER PASSED ON TO THE
INSURANCE COMPANIES WE SEE.
RISING PREMIUMS EVERY YEAR IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA AND IS
OPEN ENROLLMENT -- THERE NEEDS
TO BE SOME FAIRNESS TO THIS LAW
THERE NEEDS TO BE SOME LOGICAL
EXCUSES -- THE ALLOW HOSPITALS
TO USE THEIR BEST EFFORTS. TO
MAKE SURE THOSE RATIOS ARE IN
FACT IN PLACE IN THE BEST
INTEREST OF THE PATIENT SAFETY.
I THINK THE BILL IS TO PUNITIVE
I THINK IT'S TOO RIGID AND FOR
THOSE REASONS I REGION OF THANK
YOU US SENATOR CAFIERO.
F. FOLLOWED BY SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MADAM SPEAKER --
QUESTION OF THE AUTHOR.
WOULD YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION I
WOULD.
CENTER COVER EUROPE YOU MAKERS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THROUGH THE
PRO TEM -- MY CONCERN IS ARE THE
SMALL RURAL HOSPITALS OF WHICH I
HAVE MANY MANY IN MY DISTRICT --
AND THEY OPERATE ON REALLY SLIM
MARGINS -- THE LAST THING I
THINK WE WANT IS TO DRIVE THE
SMALL HOSPITALS OUT OF BUSINESS
BECAUSE THEN WE'D HAVE NO
HOSPITAL IN SOME OF OUR RURAL.
COUNTIES AND SO I WONDER IF YOU
COULD ADDRESS HOW YOUR BILL --
HANDLES SMALL RURAL.
HOSPITALS AND IN IN YOUR
THOUGHTS MOVING FORWARD BECAUSE
I I DID SUPPORT THIS LAST YEAR
WHEN I WAS IN THE ASSEMBLY-- I
WANT TO BE SUPPORTIVE BUT I AM
CONCERNED ABOUT MY RURAL
HOSPITALS THANK YOU SENATOR I
APPRECIATE THAT QUESTION.
SO CURRENTLY UNDER CURRENT LAW
ON THIS BILL DOES NOT CHANGE
THIS -- RURAL HOSPITALS CAN
APPLY FOR A WAIVER AND THE RATIO
IF THEY'RE HAVING TROUBLE
RECRUITING NURSES AND THEY FEEL
THAT THEY WILL BE OUT OF RATIO.
A RECENT STUDY WAS DONE AND IN
THE PAST FIVE YEARS NO RURAL
HOSPITAL HAS PULLED A WAIVER SO
THEY STILL HAVE ACCESS TO THAT
BUT THAT LEADS ME TO BELIEVE
THAT THEY'RE NOT HAVING A
PROBLEM RECRUITING.
BUT ALSO TWO TWO SEVEN MY
CURRENT BILL CLARIFIES THAT CV
PH WILL TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION
THE SPECIAL CIRCUMSTANCES OF
SMALL AND RURAL HOSPITALS.
PRIOR TO ADMINISTERING A FINE SO
I THINK THAT WE HAVE EVEN
STRENGTHENED THE LANGUAGE FOR
SMALL AND RURAL HOSPITALS.
THANK YOU FOR THE QUESTION.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
COLLEAGUES YOU KNOW I CERTAINLY
pCLEARLY SUPPORT.
THE FIGHT FOR BETTER
INAPPROPRIATE PATIENT CARE IN
OUR HOSPITAL INSTITUTIONS -- I
SUPPORTED THIS BILL LAST YEAR --
WITH SOME NOTABLE CHANGES FROM
THE CURRENT VERSION.
AND I INTEND TO SUPPORT OF THE
BILL TO MOVE IT OFF THE FLOOR.
THIS YEAR BUT I CERTAINLY EXPECT
THE RESTORATION OF THE
PROVISIONS IN LAST YEAR'S BILL
BEFORE WE SEE IT BACK HERE.
ON THIS FLOOR ON THE COMEBACK
SPECIFICALLY.
THE RESTORATION OF THE
UNEXPECTED ILLNESS AND INJURY
EXCEPTION THAT WAS IN LAST
YEAR'S BILL.
OF THE ADJUSTMENT DOWNWARD OF
THE RESET TO PROVISION FROM SIX
YEARS TO THREE YEARS SINCE SOME
ADJUSTMENT.
IN THE FIND SCHEDULE AND I'M
CONFIDENT THAT MY COLLEAGUE --
WILL BE WORKING ON THAT AS THIS
BILL MOVES OFF THIS FLOOR INTO
THE ASSEMBLY AND THEN BACK TO US.
FOR CONCURRENCE AND WITH THAT --
AT THIS POINT I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE
ON THIS -- ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU SENATOR ROBB SEEING NO
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR LEYVA YOU MAY CLOSE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I
THINK MY COLLEAGUES FOR THE
DISCUSSION AND FOR THE QUESTIONS.
MEMBERS THIS BILL IS ABOUT
MAKING SURE THAT OUR STAFFING
RATIOS ARE UP TO PAR SO THAT
NONE OF OUR LOVED ONES OR ANYONE
ELSE'S LOVED ONES ARE PUT AT
RISK.
AND THE NURSES ARE PUT AT RISK
YOU DON'T BECOME A NURSE IF YOU
DON'T HAVE A DEEP CARE AND
CONCERN ABOUT HUMAN BEINGS.
WE ONLY HAVE TO INSTITUTE A
PENALTY BECAUSE FOR TWENTY YEARS
TWENTY PLUS YEARS THERE HAS BEEN
A NURSE STAFFING RATIO BUT IT
HASN'T BEEN COMPLIED WITH.
AND SOMETIMES UNTIL THERE'S A
HAMMER.
FOLKS JUST WON'T DO WHAT THEY
NEED TO DO SO I AS I SAID BEFORE
I AM COMMITTED TO WORKING --
GOING FORWARD IT WOULD BE GREAT
IF WE COULD GET EVERYBODY IN A
POSITION WHERE THEY SUPPORT OF
THE BILL BUT I LOOK FORWARD TO
IF HE GETS OFF THE FLOOR TODAY
WORKING ON IT AND POLICY
COMMITTEE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE THANK YOU
SENATOR LIVE ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED MISTER SECRETARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL AND I WOULD
LIKE TO KNOW WILL GO THROUGH IT
TWICE IN THE WINTER CLOTHES THE
ROLE.
SENATOR OF SHE'S ME MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
NO BELL.
I FOR JUST [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CAPPIELLO.
I CHANGED.
NO.
DODD.
NO THE RISE OF HI GALGIANI
[inaudible]
NO GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH.
NO HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
NO.
WAY SO.
BY -- TADA.
JACKSON HI I JONES.
NO.
LEYVA.
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
I MITCHELL [inaudible]
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LARK.
NO MORALE [inaudible]
NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
HI PORTANTINO.
I ROTH HI RUBIO.
SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
HI STONE [inaudible]
NO NUMBER.
BYE BYE COUNTY. FIVE WIENER AYE
WILK.
NO.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
I GLAZER BEGAN -- TADO
[inaudible]
RUBIO.
OUR EYES TWENTY ONE KNOWS
THIRTEEN THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM TWENTY
SENATOR CHIANG MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL TWO
FORTY FIVE BY SENATOR CHIANG AN
ACT RELATING TO PUBLIC ANIMAL
SHELTERS.
SENATOR CHIANG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT GOOD
MORNING COLLEAGUES TODAY I AM
HERE TO PRESENT SB TWO FORTY
FIVE OR WHAT I LIKE TO REFER TO
AS THE PETS FOR VETS ACT.
THIS BILL WOULD WAIVE ADOPTION
FEES AT LOCAL PUBLIC ANIMAL
SHELTERS FOR MILITARY VETERANS.
MANY OF WHOM SEEK EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT COMPANIONS THROUGH THE
PUBLIC SHELTER SYSTEM.
CALIFORNIA IS HOME TO NEARLY TWO
MILLION VETERANS SOME OF WHOM
ARE COPING WITH PTSD OR OTHER
SERVICE RELATED MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS.
ANIMAL COMPANIONS HAVE BEEN
SHOWN TO LOWER DEPRESSION LOWER
LEVELS OF SOCIAL ISOLATION AND
PROVIDE AN OVERALL GREATER
SATISFACTION WITH LIFE.
THIS LEGISLATION WOULD BE
AVAILABLE TO ALL VETERANS IN
RECOGNITION OF THEIR SERVICE TO
OUR COUNTRY BUT THOSE WHO TURN
TO ANIMAL COMPANIONS COPE WITH
PTSD AND OTHER MENTAL HEALTH
CONDITIONS WILL ESPECIALLY
BENEFIT.
AS A LONGTIME DOG OWNER CAN
ATTEST THE JOY OF HAD BRING TO
ONE'S LIFE.
THIS WILL OPEN THE DOOR FOR SO
MANY VETERANS SEEKING
COMPANIONSHIP AND EMOTIONAL
SUPPORT THROUGH PATRICK OPTION.
I RECENTLY MET WITH LORRAINE SEE
ON A U. S. ARMY VETERAN WHO
SERVED SIX YEARS IN IRAQ.
AND SHE TOLD ME THAT HER SISTER
HAD SUGGESTED.
THE ADOPTION OF A PACT WHICH HE
HAD TO BORROW MONEY FROM HER
FAMILY MEMBERS IN ORDER.
TO ADOPT.
SB TWO FORTY FIVE IN THIS LEASE
WE CAN DO FOR MEN AND WOMEN WHO
PROBABLY SERVED OUR COUNTRY I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NICE.
THANK YOU DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SEEING AND HEARING NONE I'M
SORRY MR ARCHER LETTER.
PARDON ME SENATOR ARCHULETA THE
FLOOR IS YOURS.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I'D
LIKE -- TO STATE MY SUPPORT FOR
THE BILL.
JUST RECENTLY WE SAW SO MANY.
LAW ENFORCEMENT OFFICIALS AND
MEMBERS OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
OUT HERE.
JUST STEPS FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
AND SO MANY ARE VETERANS.
BUT HERE.
IS THE OTHER DAY WE ACKNOWLEDGE
THOSE WHO LOST THEIR LIVES.
CAN YOU IMAGINE OUR MILITARY
VETERANS WOULD COME HOME.
WITH DISABILITIES NOT ONLY
PHYSICAL MENTALLY.
IN THIS BILL WILL ALLOW THEM TO
HAVE THAT COMPANION AND I THINK
WE OWE IT TO THEM AND I URGENT
YOUR AYE BOAT THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATER
DISCUSSION SEEING AND HEARING
NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES.
I BILL I PORGES.
I BRADFORD [inaudible]
CABALLERO.
I CHIANG.
I DOT [inaudible]
I DORADO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER.
BY GROW.
BY HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI HI JONES
[inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL.
REQUIRE AYE MITCHELL AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK I'M RAIL
[inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN AYE STONE.
I AMBER.
OUR COUNTY [inaudible]
WIENER THE BY WILK COLLEAGUES.
WELCOME COLLEAGUES WHO TRYING TO
ESTABLISH I BELIEVE THERE'S
SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES WERE
TRYING TO GET TO ARE YOU.
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL SO PLEASE --
IF YOU ARE.
ANYWHERE IN THE HALL PLEASE
REGISTER YOUR VOTE SO WE CAN
MOVE MY LETTERS ON A LITTLE BIT
MORE QUICKLY PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS HI [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY.
NIELSEN.
HI.
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
NO.
OUR EYES THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ONE
THE MEASURE PASSES AND WE WILL
TRY YET AGAIN FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL THANK YOU CENTER CHIANG
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON NOW TO
FILE ITEM.
TWENTY ONE SENATOR RUBIO MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL THREE OH NINE BY
SENATOR RUBIO AND ACCOLADES
TAXATION TO DECLINE THERE'S THE
RUBTAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU GOOD MORNING MADAM
PRESIDENT AND MEMBERS I TâM
PRESENTING AS FEET THE REAL NINE
WHICH WOULD REMOVE THE MINIMUM
DONATION REQUIREMENT FOR THE
CALIFORNIA SENIOR LEGISLATURE.
TO REMAIN ON THE VOLUNTARY TAX
INCOME ORM AND ANSWER REPEAL
DATE OF JANUARY FIRST TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE THE CALIFORNIA
SENIOR LEGISLATURE ALSO KNOWN AS
CSL.
THE STATUTORY AT AUTHORIZED BODY
DEDICATED TO ENHANCING THE
QUALITY OF LIFE FOR OLDER
CALIFORNIANS AND THEIR FAMILIES
SINCE THEN.
OVER TWO HUNDRED CFL PROPOSALS
HAVE BEEN SIGNED AND ENACTED
INTO LAW WE ADDED AN URGENCY
CLASS BECAUSE HE'LL SELL.
A PROJECT THAT WILL NOT MEET
THEIR MINIMUM TO THEIR THRESHOLD
REQUIREMENT TO AND THAT FISCAL
YEAR WITHOUT THIS BILL THE
AGENCY WILL FALL OFF THE INCOME
TAX FORM SO WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOVEL.
THANK YOU SENATOR RUBIO ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
ANY THE OLD FOLKS WANT TO
TESTIFY HERE IN PRISON AND
SENATOR STONE.
YES I'M ONE OF THOSE OLD FOLKS
IN A ONE OF A PLOT MY COLLEAGUE --
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD -- I
HAD A WONDERFUL LADY NAMED MRS
APPLE TERROR -- WHO WAS ON THE
SENIOR -- LEGISLATURE WHEN I WAS --
CITY COUNCILMAN AND TO MACULA.
IN AS WE SEEING THE THE GRAIN OF
OUR SOCIETY THE SERVER SALAMI
THEY'RE CALLING IT -- WE'RE
GONNA NEED A LOT OF ISSUES
RESOLVED FOR SENIOR CITIZENS IN
THE YEARS TO COME BUT NOT ALL IN
CALIFORNIA BUT THROUGHOUT THE
COUNTRY AND AND THE SEA THE
LEGISLATURE REALLY GIVES A VOICE
TO THE SENIORS AND AND THE
ISSUES THAT THE THAT AFFECT THEM --
IMPACT THEM AND SO -- IT'S
UNFORTUNATE THAT -- BECOMES --
BUDGETARY ISSUE AS TO WHETHER OR
NOT WE CONTINUE -- TO GIVE THE
SENIOR CITIZENS OF VOICE BUT
APPOINT OUT OF THIS AND
CERTAINLY ISN'T THE REASON MY
BUT AS A STRONG DEDICATED VOTING
BLOC IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
THEY HAVE A VOICE THAT DESERVES
TO BE HEARD AND FOR THOSE
REASONS I URGE ABOUT.
ANY FURTHER DEBATER DISCUSSION.
SEEING AND HEARING ON SENATOR
RUBIO YOU MAY CLOSE.
I APPRECIATE THE KIND COMMENTS
WITHOUT A HOUSE FOR AN AYE VOTE
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
ALL DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
AYE BILL.
BY PORGES [inaudible]
I BRADFORD.
I CABALLERO I CHIANG
[inaudible]
I DOT.
HI THERE ALSO.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH.
I HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
HI JACKSON I JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
AYE MOORLACH I'M A REAL
[inaudible]
I NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH AYE RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
HI MY COUNTY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS GLAZER [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
RESERVE GROW YEAH [inaudible]
NO SERVICE
.
SENATOR OF RUBIO MOVES A CALL
[inaudible]
OF WE NOW WILL MOVE TO FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE FILE ITEM TWENTY
THREE WHICH IS -- SENATOR STERN.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SEVEN SIXTY SIX BY
SENATOR STERN AND ACRYLATES
ENERGY.
SENATOR STORE THANK YOU MADAM
CHAIR MEMBERS -- WE'VE MADE
SIGNIFICANT STRIDES OVER THE
RECENT YEARS IN.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY IN THE STATE.
WEATHER IS ASIANS AN INCREDIBLY
VIABLE WAY TO SAVE MONEY FOR
HOMEOWNERS AND REDUCE GREENHOUSE
GAS EMISSIONS AT THE SAME TIME.
THIS BILL WOULD INCLUDE WATER
EFFICIENCY MEASURES IN OUR
APPROACH TO WEATHERIZATION WE
KNOW THAT THERE'S A NEXUS TO
WATER AND ENERGY IN FACT 20% OF
THE ENERGY WE USE IN THIS STATE.
IS FOR MOVING HEATING IN
TREATING WATER SO WHEN YOU SAVE
WATER AT HOME YOU ACTUALLY
REDUCE OVERALL -- ENERGY
CONSUMPTION AND GREENHOUSE GAS
EMISSIONS NUMBER IN THE PROCESS
SO WE THINK IS A GOOD
COMMONSENSE MEASURE.
THAT WILL SAVE HOMEOWNERS
ESPECIALLY THE MOST LOW INCOME
HOMEOWNERS AND RENTERS MONEY
WITH THAT RESPECTFULLY ASK DR.
THANK YOU THERE'S AN INDICATION
OF SUPPORT ON BOTH SIDES HISTORY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS.
AYE BATES AYE BILL.
I PORGES.
HI BRADFORD [inaudible]
HI CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD [inaudible]
I DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL.
I WITH A HI -- TITLE.
I JACKSON I JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING BY MORE LOCK
[inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH BY RUBIO.
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN AYE STONE.
BY NUMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY.
BY WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORE LUCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
SENATOR STERN MOVES A CALL
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM A TWENTY
FIVE SENATOR HILL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR HILL AN ACTOR LINDA
CIVIL LAW SENATOR HILL THANK YOU
MADAM PRESIDENT COLLEAGUES.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX BUILDS UPON
LAST YEAR'S AS P. SEVEN TWENTY
ONE WHICH I AUTHORED TO ADDRESS
BALCONY INSPECTIONS AND REPAIRS
FOR APARTMENT BUILDINGS.
FOLLOWING THE DEADLY TWENTY
FIFTEEN BERKELEY BALCONY
COLLAPSE THAT KILLED SIX AND
INJURED.
SEVEN SB THREE TWENTY SIX
REQUIRES AN EXISTING CONDOMINIUM
BUILDINGS GOVERNED BY HOMEOWNERS
ASSOCIATIONS HAVE INSPECTIONS AT
LEAST ONCE EVERY NINE YEARS ON A
SMALL PERCENTAGE OF THEIR
BALCONIES STAIR WELLS AND OTHER.
EXTERIOR ELEVATED ELEMENTS TO
ENSURE THEY ARE SAFE.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX ALSO
PREVENTION BUILDERS FROM PLACING
LANGUAGE IN IN NATURE WAYS
COVENANTS CONDITIONS AND
RESTRICTIONS OR CCAR'S.
THAT WOULD LIMIT THE ABILITY OF
THE H. AWAY BOARD OF DIRECTORS
TO SUE THE DEVELOPER IF THERE
ARE CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS.
THIS IS NOT A HYPOTHETICAL
SITUATION A CASE IS CURRENTLY
BEING LITIGATED IN SAN FRANCISCO
WHERE A ROUTINE WATER LEAK
REVEALED THAT A MAIN WALKWAY ON
THE THIRD FLOOR WAS ABOUT TO
COLLAPSE DUE TO WOULD DRIVE.
WHEN THE H. AWAY BOARD ATTEMPTED
TO FILE A CIVIL SUIT AGAINST THE
DEVELOPER THEY FOUND
REQUIREMENTS IN THEIR CCAR'S?
PLACED THERE BY THE DEVELOPER
THAT REQUIRED A FULL MEMBER VOTE
BEFORE THEY COULD LEGALLY SEEK
DAMAGES THAT TOOK THE BOARD NINE
MONTHS.
GOVERNMENTS TO CONDUCT THE
MEMBER VOTE IN THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS ON CONSTRUCTION
DEFECT LAWSUITS NEARLY RAN OUT.
THIS IS A SITUATION BECOMING ALL
TOO COMMON.
THESE DEVELOPER AUTHORED
PROVISIONS CAN REQUIRE AS MUCH
AS AN 80% MAJORITY VOTE.
BEFORE THEY CAN BE SUED FOR
CONSTRUCTION DEFECTS AND CAN
CONVENIENTLY.
THESE PROVISIONS ARE OFTEN
PRECLUDED FROM BEING REMOVED
WITHOUT THE DEVELOPERS CONSENT.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX DOES NOT
TAKE AWAY THE HOMEOWNERS RIGHT
TO VOTE ON BOARD ACTIONS IT
PRESERVES EACH H. ALWAYS RIGHT
TO DECIDE HOW THEY WANT THEIR
ASSOCIATION GOVERNED.
BY KEEPING DEVELOPERS FROM
INSERTING POISON PILL
REQUIREMENTS THIS MEASURE PLACES
THE DECISION MAKING POWER.
SQUARELY IN THE HANDS OF THE
HOMEOWNERS.
SB THREE TWENTY SIX DOES NOT
PROHIBIT DISCLOSURES OF ANY KIND
PRIOR TO LITIGATION IN FACT.
IT DOESN'T CHANGE ANY OF THE
EXISTING PRE LITIGATION
REQUIREMENT TAKE CHOI BOARD
STILL HAVE TO ENTER INTO A ONE
HUNDRED EIGHTY DAY DISPUTE
RESOLUTION PERIOD.
WITH THE DEVELOPER BEFORE FILING
A CIVIL SUIT.
THEY THEN HAVE TO DELIVER
WRITTEN NOTICE TO ALL HOMEOWNERS
AND HOLD A MEETING TO DISCUSS
THE POTENTIAL ACTION.
THERE ARE NO PROHIBITIONS ON
WHAT IS DISCUSSED AT THE MEETING
HE OPPOSITION RECENTLY RAISED
CONCERNS.
ABOUT LANGUAGE IN THE BILL THAT
MAY PREVENT HOMEOWNERS IN LARGE
DEVELOPMENTS FROM CHANGING THEIR
GOVERNING DOCUMENTS.
THAT CERTAINLY NOT OUR INTENT --
AND THEY ALSO RAISE THAT THERE
WERE SOME QUESTIONS RAISED.
THEY ALSO RAISE THE QUESTION
THAT THAT REGARDING THE TIMING
OF NOTIFICATIONS OF HOMEOWNERS
PRIOR TO THE FILING OF A AWSUIT
WE WILL WORK WITH THEM BUT IT'S
CERTAINLY NOT OUR INTENT TO
CREATE ANY PROBLEMS IN THIS AREA --
AND WE WILL CERTAINLY WORK WITH
THE UP THE STAKEHOLDERS IN THE
ASSEMBLY OF THE BILL MOVED IN
THAT DIRECTION SO I RESPECTFULLY
ASK RIVAL COLLEAGUES.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM WILL STAR WAS SENATOR BATES
FOLLOWED BY SENATOR MORALE.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I JUST
A QUESTION FOR THE AUTHOR.
EXCEPT THE QUESTION YES THEY
WITHOUT OBJECTION.
HI -- I'M I'M A LITTLE CONFUSED
BECAUSE IN COMMITTEE IT SEEMS
THAT HOMEOWNERS WE'RE NOT GOING
TO BE ALLOWED TO VOTE.
ON THAT LITIGATION OUR YEAR
PRESENTATION NOW SUGGEST THAT AT
SOME.
POINT THEY WOULD IF NOT HAVE A
VOTE WOULD BE TOTALLY APPRISED
OF THE ACTION THAT WAS GONNA BE
TAKEN BEFORE IT WAS TAKEN.
IS THAT CORRECT THEY WOULD BE
NOTIFIED OF THE ACTION BUT THEY
WOULD NOT HAVE A VOTE IS THAT
ACTION THAT WOULD BE LEFT TO THE
BOARD OF DIRECTORS.
WOULD THAT NOTIFICATION INCLUDE
A DISCUSSION OF THE POSITIVE AND
NEGATIVE OF POTENTIAL POSITIVE
AND NEGATIVE OUTCOMES OF THAT.
ACTION THAT THE BOARD MEMBERS
SPECIFICALLY IN SINGLE YOU CAN
TAKE THE NOTIFICATION IS IN
EXISTING LAW TODAY WE'RE NOT
CHANGING WHATEVER IS IN THE
EXISTING LAW.
THE THE QUESTION THAT WAS RAISED
BY THE OPPOSITION WAS THE TIMING
OF THAT NOTIFICATION WITH THAT
NOTIFICATION WOULD COME.
PRIOR TO THE ACTION OF THE BOARD
OF DIRECTORS -- FOR AFTER THAT
NOTIFICATION I FRANKLY FEEL AND
I BELIEVE THE OPPOSITION'S
CORRECTED THAT NOTIFICATION
SHOULD COME BEFORE THE ACTION OF
THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS AND WE
WILL MAKE THOSE -- A CHANGES IN
THE IN THE ASSEMBLY.
I HOPE THAT IT WILL ON MY OWN
TIME ENEMIES WITH AND I DO HOPE
THAT IT WILL BE A MORE EXPANSIVE.
BECAUSE I BELIEVE PROHIBITING
THE HOMEOWNERS FROM AT LEAST
UNDERSTANDING THE IMPACTS OF BOB
POTENTIAL -- LITIGATION THE
NEGATIVE AND THE POSITIVE
OUTCOMES.
CONSIDERING THAT THAT FALLS ON A
DOWN IF THERE'S SIGNIFICANT
ASSESSMENTS AND IN THE FAILURE
OF THAT ACTION ARE KEEPING THEM
pFAILURE OF THE BOARD MEMBERS OF
THE FIELD THEIR FIDUCIARY DUTIES
AND PROBABLY MOST IMPORTANTLY.
TO THE GREATER MEMBERSHIP BOB
ARE THEY A PLACE TO GREET AMOUNT
OF TRUST IN THEIR BOARD MEMBERS
AND I THINK WE TALK ABOUT THAT
HERE IN TERMS OF ON
ACCOUNTABILITY AND TRANSPARENCY.
BASICALLY ABOUT IS LACKING ARE
OUT IN THE IN THE WAY I READ THE
BILL IN TERMS OF WHAT WOULD BE
PROVIDED TO HOMEOWNERS AND
SYDNEY SITTING ON A NUMBER OF
BOARDS OVER THE COURSE OF TIME
I'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN.
LOCAL ISSUES -- SOME MEMBERS SO
I'D GET ON BOARD SPECIFICALLY TO
ADVANCE THEIR OWN CAUSES.
AND OUTPUT FOR THE ENTIRE --
HOMEOWNER ASSOCIATION IN
JEOPARDY IF THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S REALLY HAPPENING AND IT
HAPPENED.
TO HAPPEN MANY YEARS AGO AND
ASSOCIATION AND I'M A MEMBER OF
SO OUR I MESSED OPPOSE THAT I
HOLD GOING FORWARD.
I TAKE INTO CONSIDERATION SOME
AMENDMENTS THE PROVIDE MORE
ANALYSIS AND AND NOTIFICATION
BEFORE THOSE ACTIONS ARE TAKEN.
THANK YOU.
I URGE A NO VOTE [inaudible]
THANK YOU [inaudible]
SENATOR ARCHULETA.
THANK YOU BETTER PRESENT FIRST
OF ALL I RISE TO SUPPORT THE
BILL.
HOWEVER I'VE SPOKEN WITH THE
AUTHOR AND HE ASSURES ME THEY'LL
BE SOME ADJUSTMENTS MADE
REFERENCE TO THE VOTING THE
PEOPLE VOTING ACROSS THE BOARD
OF ALL THE MEMBERS.
OF THE ASSOCIATION AND THE THE
THE THE OWNERS COMPLETELY THAT
EVERYONE HAD THAT OPPORTUNITY
AND TO BE ABLE TO SAY AND PUT IN
THEIR SAY IN REFERENCE TO WHAT
MAY HAPPEN.
IN THE FUTURE AND I'VE BEEN A
CHURCH SO I SUPPORT THE BILL
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION SING IN HEARING ON
SENATOR HILL YOU MAKE THANK
THANK YOU VENTURE YOU WANT TO BE
CLEAR THAT THE WHAT WE ARE
TRYING TO ELIMINATE IN THIS
LEGISLATION IS THE REQUIREMENT
THAT THERE BE A VOTE OF THE
ENTIRE MEMBERSHIP -- THAT HAS
BEEN PLACED IN SOME OF THE C. C.
IN ART BY THE DEVELOPER AND AND
THE BUILDER OF THE THE COMPLEX
THAT IS.
KIND OF AN A VERY -- CUMBERSOME
AND IN VERY DIFFICULT PROCESS
THAT WHAT WE WILL MAKE SURE IS
THAT THE BOARD BE NOTIFIED.
THAT THEN THEY CAN BEFORE IT
WHICH I FEEL IT SHOULD BE BEFORE
PRIOR TO THE BOARD OF DIRECTORS
TAKING ANY ACTION.
THE MEMBER SHOULD BE ADVISED IN
AND HAVE THE ABILITY TO TO TO
WEIGH IN ON THAT DECISION BEFORE
IT HAPPENS THAT'S WHAT -- WE
WILL BE LOOKING AT IN THE
ASSEMBLY I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
RIVAL COLLEGE THINKING Q. ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS AYE BATES.
NO BELL [inaudible]
BY BURGESS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
BY CARRIER [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG.
I HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TITLE.
BY JACKSON.
HI JONES NO [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE HI MITCHELL.
BY MORNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NO [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH.
I RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
BY STONE.
NO I'M BURKE.
IRAQ OWSKI.
AYE WIENER AYE WILK.
NO PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WERE JUST [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK.
OUR EYES TWENTY EIGHT NO SIX THE
MEASURE PASSES MOVING
[inaudible]
I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY BUT WE'RE GONNA MOVE A
CALL ON THAT ITEM WE DO HAVE
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR.
IT WOULD BE HELPFUL IF WE COULD
GET THEM BACK.
ALRIGHT MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
ROLL
.
TWENTY SEVEN PART WE'RE GOING TO
LEAVE THE CALL ON FILE ITEM
TWENTY ONE LET'S LOOK THE CALL.
ON FILE ITEM.
TWENTY ONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ON FILE ITEM [inaudible]
TWENTY ONE NIELSEN [inaudible]
HI.
ON THE ICE THIRTY EIGHT NOTES
HERE ON THE URGENCY ICE THIRTY
EIGHT NO ZERO ON THE MEASURE.
ALL RIGHT WE ARE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM. TWENTY SEVEN FILE ITEM
TWENTY SEVEN SENATOR UMBERG.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE FREE
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY FOUR BY
SENATOR UMBERG AND NATURALLY TO
ATTORNEYS SENATOR UMBERG.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT AND
EMBERS I RISE TO PRESENT SB
FIVE FOUR FOUR WHICH WOULD
PROHIBIT THE CALIFORNIA STATE
BAR FROM ASKING APPLICANTS TO
SIGN MEDICAL WAIVERS. FOR THEIR
MENTAL HEALTH HISTORY OF WHAT
THIS DOES THIS WAIVER.
CREATES A SITUATION WHERE FOR
EXAMPLE LAW STUDENT WHO IS
SEEKING TREATMENT FOR SEXUAL
ASSAULT OR PTSD IS DISSUADED.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW THAT THESE
RECORDS MAY BECOME AVAILABLE THE
BAR -- I REGION I BOUGHT.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM SEEING
AND HEARING NONE.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL.
ALLEN [inaudible]
HI.
ARCHULETA.
AYE ATKINS AYE BATES.
AYE BELL.
BY PORCHES I BRADFORD.
BY KELLY AT ALL.
I CHANGE.
I DOT.
BY THE RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER AYE GROWTH [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
I HILL [inaudible]
I HUESO.
HI.
THE TITLE.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
LEYVA.
I AM A CHOIR.
BY MITCHELL BY MONEY.
I'M MORE LOCKED [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
AYE RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AMBERG.
IOWA COUNTY I WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GROWTH [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NIELSEN I SENATOR UMBERG MOVES
TO CALL MOVING ON NOW COLLEAGUES
TO FILE ITEM THIRTY SEVEN FILE
ITEM.
THIRTY SEVEN PASS ON FILE FILE
ITEM THIRTY NINE SENATOR WIENER
DO YOU WISH TO TAKE UP FILE ITEM.
THIRTY NINE ONE FILE ITEM THIRTY
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
READ SENATE BILL TWO SEVENTY ONE
BY SENATOR WINNER AND ACT REALLY
TO IMPLEMENT MAKING A
PREPARATION THEREFORE SENATOR
WINNER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT.
HI COLLEAGUES SB TWO SEVENTY ONE
IS -- NARROWLY CRAFTED MEASURE
OR TO ENSURE THAT ONE
CALIFORNIANS -- ARE WHO ARE
WORKING IN THE FILM INDUSTRY
LEAVE CALIFORNIA ON ASSIGNMENT --
SAY FOR A MOVIE OR A TV --
FILMING -- THAT THEY'RE STILL
ABLE TO ACCESS DISABILITY -- AND
PAID FAMILY LEAVE -- EVEN THOUGH
THEY ARE AT THE MOMENT WORKING
OUTSIDE OF CALIFORNIA -- RIGHT
NOW THERE IS A LACK OF CLARITY
AND SO WHEN YOU HAVE A FILM
EMPLOYEES WHO ARE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS EMPLOYED IN CALIFORNIA.
BUT WORKING IN VARIOUS PARTS OF
THE COUNTRY -- AT TIMES --
DISABILITY IS NOT WITHHELD FROM
THEIR PAYCHECKS.
AND SO WHEN THEY DON'T HAVE TO
ACCESS THOSE BENEFITS -- THEY
LEARN OFTEN THEIR SURPRISED TO
LEARN -- THAT THEY HAVE THE
MINIMUS BENEFITS -- THIS BILL
WILL CLARIFY THAT THE PERSON IS
A CALIFORNIA RESIDENT IS
EMPLOYED IN CALIFORNIA BUT
HAPPENS TO BE WORKING IN VARIOUS
PARTS OF THE COUNTRY IN THE FILM
INDUSTRY.
THAT THEY WILL HAVE DISABILITY
WITH HELD IN CALIFORNIA SO THAT
THEY WILL HAVE ACCESS TO THOSE
FULL BENEFITS.
THE BILL IS US SPONSORED BY A
VARIAS STILLMAN ENTERTAINMENT
INDUSTRY -- EMPLOYEE -- UNIONS --
AND IS SUPPORTED BY THE
CALIFORNIA LABOR FEDERATION I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER ANY
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
I BY ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
HI BILL.
I PORGES.
BY BRADFORD.
I CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHANGED [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
DODD.
I THE RAZA.
BY GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL.
AYE HUESO.
HI FOR TITLE [inaudible]
HI JACKSON.
BY JONES.
BY LEYVA.
AYE MCGUIRE AYE [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
HI ROSS BY RUBIO [inaudible]
BY SKINNER.
BY STERN.
AYE STONE.
BY AMBERG.
FILER CASSIE I WINNER BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH.
MORE LOCKED.
NIELSEN.
CARD SENATOR WINNER MOVES A CALL
FILE ITEM FORTY THREE COLLEGE
SHOWS THAT WERE OR WHERE WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE A HARD STOP PHONE
BILLS ADD A TEN FORTY FIVE TO DO
OUR ADJOURN IN MEMORIES WE WILL
HAVE A VERY HARD STOP AT ELEVEN
O'CLOCK SO.
WE'RE TRYING TO GET AS MUCH DONE
AS WE CAN AND WE OULD ASK THAT
YOU ALL PLEASE STAY ON THE FLOOR
SO WE CAN.
HAVE OUR VOTES OF FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE SENATOR JONES ARE
YOU PREPARED TO TAKE THIS UP.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE EIGHTY FIVE A
SENATOR JONES AND THEY'RE GOING
TO PROFESSIONS AND VOCATIONS
CENTER JONES MADAM PRESIDENT SB
THREE EIGHTY FIVE THREE EIGHTY
FIVE IS A VERY SIMPLE BILL.
UPDATES THE PRIVATE INVESTIGATOR
ACTS TO IMPROVE CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM SEEING AND HEARING NONE
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
I PORGES.
I BRADFORD.
HI KELLY ERA I CHIANG
[inaudible]
BY DOT.
I TO RAZA [inaudible]
I GALGIANI.
I GLAZER.
AYE GROVE.
HERTZBERG AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY OUR TITLE.
BY JACKSON I JONES [inaudible]
I LEYVA.
I AM ACQUIRE BY MITCHELL
[inaudible]
BY MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
WELL [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO.
I ROTH.
BY RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER.
I STERN.
AYE STONE.
I AM BURKE.
I WOULD COUNTY BY WINNER.
BY WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH.
MORE LUCK.
NIELSEN.
SENATOR JONES MOVES TO CALL FILE
ITEM FORTY FOUR SENATOR MONNING
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL THREE NINETY ONE BY
SENATOR MINING AND ACT RULING
THE BUSINESS CENTER MONNING.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS THE BUREAU OF HOUSEHOLD
GOODS AND SERVICES OVER SEASON
REGULATE.
HOUSEHOLD MOVERS BY CONTRACTING
SPECIAL INVESTIGATORS TO CITE
MOVERS WHO VIOLATE THE LAW.
SB THREE NINETY ONE CLARIFIES
THE AUTHORITY OF A PERSON
EMPLOYED AS A SPECIAL
INVESTIGATOR BY THE BUREAU OF
HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND SERVICES. TO
ISSUE A WRITTEN NOTICE TO APPEAR
IN COURT FOR MISDEMEANOR
VIOLATIONS.
MEMBERS THIS BILL ALLOWS THE
BUREAU HOUSEHOLD GOODS AND
SERVICES TO EFFECTIVELY PROTECT
CONSUMERS I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ALLEN.
I ARCHULETA I ATKINS
[inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
I BILL.
I PORGES.
AYE BRADFORD.
I CARRIER.
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER BY GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL.
I WITH SO.
HI -- TADO.
BY JACKSON HI I JONES
[inaudible]
HI LEYVA.
I MCGUIRE AYE MITCHELL.
BY MONEY.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
I NIELSEN.
PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
BY ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO.
I SKINNER.
AYE STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
HI NUMBER.
I WOULD COUNTY I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
MORE LOCKED.
NIELSEN STERN HI.
SENATOR MORNING MOVES A CALL
FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE SENATOR HILL.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY EIGHT BY
SENATOR HILL AN ACT RELATING TO
ELECTRICITY.
SENATOR HILL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT SB
FIVE FORTY EIGHT ADDRESSES A
CURRENT GAP IN UTILITY SAFETY
REGULATIONS.
AND REQUIREMENTS THAT IS THE
INSPECTION OF TRANSMISSION
INFRASTRUCTURE.
UTILITIES CURRENTLY HAVE A
MINIMUM TIME LINES FOR
INSPECTING THEIR DISTRIBUTION
INFRASTRUCTURE HOWEVER NO SUCH
REQUIREMENTS EXIST FOR
INSPECTING INFRASTRUCTURE ON THE
TRANSMISSION GRID.
THIS BILL RECEIVE UNANIMOUS BY
THAT PART BIPARTISAN SUPPORT IN
ENERGY COMMITTEE OF AFFECT V. S.
RIVAL COLLEAGUES DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM ANY
DEBATER DISCUSSION SEEING AND
HEARING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
[inaudible]
OUR I ARCHULETA.
I ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BY BILL.
I PORGES I BRADFORD.
AYE CAMBIADO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
I DODD.
BY THE RAZA.
I GALGIANI.
AYE GLAZER AYE GROVE.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO -- TADA.
I JACKSON HI BY JONES
[inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE.
BY MITCHELL.
AYE MONNING.
BY MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORALE [inaudible]
BY NELSON [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
BY PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
I RUBIO [inaudible]
I SKINNER [inaudible]
HI STERN [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
STONE.
I AM BURKE.
HI MY COUNTY.
I WINNER.
HI WILK.
HI PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ATKINS [inaudible]
GROW [inaudible]
HUESO [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
SENATOR HILL MOVES A CALL MOVING
ON TO FILE ITEM FIFTY FIVE
SENATOR CAFIERO.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE RE DIAL
ITEM FIFTY FIVE COLLEAGUES GUYS
SENATE BILL SEVEN TWENTY SIX BY
SENATOR CAFIERO AND AQUINNAH
HAZARDOUS WASTE.
CENTER COPIER THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I RISE
TODAY TO PRESENT SB SEVEN TWENTY
SIX ME CENTER COVER YEAR ON
TUESDAY [inaudible]
GUYS.
COULD WE HAVE PEOPLE EITHER TAKE
THEIR SEATS OR TAKE THE
CONVERSATION TO THE BACK THE
HALL SO THAT THE SENATOR CAN
PRESENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU AMIRA THANK YOU MADAM.
OP PRESIDENT I A RISE 2% SB
SEVEN TWENTY SIX WHICH IS A
STRAIGHTFORWARD BILL THAT WILL
ENSURE LOCAL GOVERNMENTS WHO
WISH TO CONTINUE OR EXPAND THEIR
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE REUSE
PROGRAMS.
IN ACCORDANCE WITH THE LAW AND
IS ENCOURAGED BY THE STATE CAN
DO SO.
THE BILL PROVIDES STATUTORY
CHANGES IT SIMPLY UPDATE THE
HEALTH AND SAFETY CODE TO ALLOW
FOR THE EXPANSION OF REUSABLE
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS MATERIAL
EXCHANGE PROGRAMS ALSO A LINE
ALLOWING JURISDICTIONS. TO MORE
EASILY TRANSPORT THESE WASTE
PRODUCTS TO OTHER SITES THAT
SUPPORT THE PROGRAMS.
THIS HAS A DIRECT BENEFIT TO
SMALL BUSINESSES AND INDIVIDUAL
HOMEOWNERS WHO NEED TO ACCESS
THESE MATERIALS THIS IS A MUCH
NEEDED IMPROVEMENT. TO THE
HOUSEHOLD HAZARDOUS WASTE
COLLECTION PROGRAM THIS BILL HAS
NO VOTE NO NO VOTES AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION IS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO.
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES.
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM.
SIXTY FILE ITEM SIXTY SENATOR
DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL SIXTY TWO BY SENATOR
DODD AN ACT RELATING TO
ENDANGERED SPECIES SENATOR DODD.
BETTER PRESENT MEMBERS SB SIXTY
TWO ADDRESSES TWO SUNSETS IN LOS
PERTAINING TO ENDANGERED SPECIES.
SB SIXTY TWO EXTENSIVE SUNSET
CONCERNING PROTECTIONS AGAINST
ACCIDENTAL TAKE OF AN ENDANGERED
SPECIES.
THE SUNSET FOR ACCIDENTAL TAKE
PROVISIONS OF LAW HAVE BEEN
RENEWED NUMEROUS TIMES IT TO OUR
KNOWLEDGE THERE BEEN NOT NOPE
WEIGHTS ABOUT STATUTE.
THE BILL AS A REQUIREMENT THAT A
FARMER WHO ACTUALLY TAKES A
SPECIES.
REPORT THE EVENT TO FISH AND
WILDLIFE SECOND THE BILL
ELIMINATES A SUBSET OF THE SAFE
HARBOR AGREEMENT ACT.
BOTH PROVISIONS HAVE MINIMAL
IMPACT FISCAL IMPACT THERE'S NO
OPPOSITION THE BILLENJOYS BROAD
SUPPORT RESPECTFULLY ASK DR A
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON THIS
ITEM.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION TO
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL SEEING AND HEARING NONE ICE
THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE
PASSES FILE ITEM SIXTY ONE
SENATOR WIENER MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL ONE SIXTY SIX BY
SENATOR WIENER AND ACT GOING TO
WATER QUALITY SENATOR WIENER.
I THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT -- COLLEAGUES THIS IS
A WATER REUSE BUILD TO TRY TO
INCREASE WATER REVIEWS --
BREWERIES AND WINERIES TO MAKE
IT EASIER -- AND MORE ARE COST
EFFECTIVE -- FOR THESE
BUSINESSES TO RECYCLE WATER
ALTHOUGH WE ARE -- TEMPORARILY
OUT OF THE DROUGHT IT WILL
RETURN WE HAVE A LONG TERM
STRUCTURAL WATER SHORTAGE IN
CALIFORNIA -- AND WATER
RECYCLING IS A KEY PART OF THE
FUTURE -- WE ARE CONTINUING TO
WORK WITH THE INDUSTRY I ON THIS
BILL -- AND I AM CONFIDENT THAT
WE WILL -- KEEP IMPROVING AT SO
THAT IT -- REALLY MOVES DIAL IN
OUR STATE I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU ANY DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
IS THERE ANY OBJECTION IS
SUBSTITUTING A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
MOVING ON TO FILE ITEM SIXTY
THREE SENATOR DODD.
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FOR FORTY TWO BY
SENATOR DODD AND ECHOING THE
STATE PARKS SENATOR DODD --
BETTER PRESENT MEMBERS SB FOUR
FOUR TWO WOULD PROVIDE A LIMITED
EXCEPTION TO CERTAIN INDIVIDUALS
AND INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION TO COMMERCIALIZE
DISCOVERIES.
THE COME FROM CALIFORNIA STATE
PARKS.
THIS BILL CREATES A NARROW
EXCEPTION THAT ALLOWS FOR
SCIENTIFIC DISCOVERIES THEY
CAN'T WILL PROVIDE NATURAL
ORGANIC SOLUTIONS LITTLE
POSSIBLY IMPACT THE ENVIRONMENT
WHILE STILL PROTECTING OUR STATE
PARKS.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR AYE.
THANK YOU SENATOR DODD DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE IS THERE
ANY OBJECTION IS SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
SEVEN NO ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK TO FILE
ITEM FORTY EIGHT WHICH IS ALSO A
MEASURE BY SENATOR DODD FILE
ITEM.
FORTY EIGHT MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ FURTHER BEFORE SIXTY
NUMBER SENATOR DODD AND ACTING A
HORSE RACING AND CLEARING THEIR
THROATS TAKE EFFECT IMMEDIATELY
SENATOR DODD META PRESIDENT
MEMBERS SP FOUR SIXTY NINE
AUTHORIZES THE CALIFORNIA HORSE
RACING BOARD. TO TEMPORARILY
SUSPEND A HORSE RICE RACING
LICENSE WHEN THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF HORSES OR JOCKEYS ARE
AT SERIOUS RISK.
ADDITIONALLY THIS BILL EXEMPTS
THE BOARD FROM THE TEN DAY
NOTIFICATION REQUIREMENTS
ALLOWING THE BOARD TO TAKE SWIFT
ACTIONS TO ADDRESS EMERGENCY
SITUATIONS.
EXISTING LAW IS INADEQUATE AND
LIMITS THE ABILITY OF THE BOARD
TO ACT QUICKLY WHEN THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF HORSES AND RIDERS
ARE AT RISK.
HORSE RACING IN CALIFORNIA HAS A
RICH HISTORY AND SUPPORTS
SEVENTEEN THOUSAND LICENSE WORSE
HORSE RACING JOBS AND THOUSANDS
MORE DIRECT AND INDIRECT JOBS
THROUGHOUT THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THE HEALTH AND SAFETY OF THE
HORSES AND JOCKEYS MUST REMAIN A
PRIORITY.
WITH THAT IN MIND I'M COMMITTED
TO WORKING WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS
AS THIS BILL MOVES FORWARD TO
ENSURE THAT THE LANGUAGE DOES
NOT RESULT.
IN UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES I
APPRECIATE THE INDUSTRY COMING
TO THE TABLE INCLUDING SANTA
ANITA FOR MAKING NUMEROUS
REFORMS AND I LOOK FORWARD. TO
CONTINUING THE CONVERSATION ON
HOW THE INDUSTRY REGULATORS AND
THE LEGISLATURE.
CAN'T BUILD UPON REFORMS THAT
ARE ALREADY UNDER WAY.
THIS BILL IS GOOD FOR THE HEALTH
AND SAFETY OF RACE HORSES AND
JOCKEYS AND GOOD FOR THE FUTURE
OF HORSE RACING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
THERE'S NO REGISTERED OPPOSITION
TO THIS BILL IT RECEIVED
UNANIMOUS SUPPORT COMMITTEE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIGHT.
THANK YOU DEBATE OR DISCUSSION
SENATOR RUBIO.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT I AM A
POPCORN AUTHOR OF THIS BILL AS
SENATOR RACE TRACK IS IN MY
DISTRICT I'D LIKE TO THANK THE
CENTER FROM APPLE FOR WORKING
WITH ME ON THIS ISSUE.
I APPRECIATE THAT WE WILL MOVE
IN A THOUGHTFUL EVIDENCE BASED
MANNER THE SAFETY OF THE HORSES
AND JOCKEYS SHOULD BE OF THE
UTMOST IMPORTANCE.
NONETHELESS THE RACETRACK IS A
LARGE ECONOMIC DRIVER AND MY
DISTRICT IT PROVIDES OVER TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED FULL TIME
JOBS AND THOUSANDS OF INDIRECT.
JOBS AS WELL AS PREVIOUSLY
MENTIONED BY THE SENATOR FROM
NOW BUT WHEN IT COMES TO THE
FINANCIAL SECURITY OF OUR
FAMILIES.
AND THE SAFETY OF OUR HORSES WE
HAVE TO ENSURE THAT THE DATA IS
CLEAR.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO COMMEND THE
STONE AGE GROUP THAT SENATOR
RACETRACK OWNERS.
ALL WHO HAVE TAKEN LEADERSHIP
AND USHERING IN REFORMS I'VE SAT
DOWN WITH THEM HAVE
CONVERSATIONS.
AND THEY HAVE COMMITTED -- ACT I
HAVE THEIR COMMITMENT DATE THAT
THEY WILL BE FACING HOUSE RACE
DAY MEDICATIONS AS WELL AS OTHER
IMPORTANT REFORMS LIKE USING MRI
FOR HORSES.
CLEARLY A LOT MORE NEEDS TO BE
DONE SO I APPRECIATE THEIR
COMMITMENT IN WORKING WITH THE
INDUSTRY AS WELL AS MYSELF TO
CRAFT VIABLE SOLUTIONS.
THESE REFORMS ALONG WITH US
BEFORE SIXTY NINE WILL LEAD TO
SYSTEM.
OF STANDS ONE FAVE HORSE RCING
INDUSTRY STANDARDS IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA WITHOUT URGE AN
AYE VOTE AS WELL THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY FURTHER DEBATE OR
DISCUSSION.
SING IN HEARING NON.
WE ARE ON FILE ITEM SIXTY FOUR
IT IS SURE ANY.
EXCUSE ME.
FORTY EIGHT AND IT APPEARS THAT
THERE IS.
SUPPORT SUPPORT IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION ENTERS THE X..
USING A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
SEEING AND HEARING ON ICE THIRTY
SEVEN THOSE HERE ON THE URGENCY
ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO ON THE
MEASURE.
COLLEAGUES WE'RE NOW GOING TO GO
TO THE CONSENT CALENDAR THEY
WERE GOING TO LIFT THE CALLS.
HAVE ANNOUNCEMENTS AND A GERMAN
MEMORY -- SO THAT WE ARE OUT OF
HERE AT ELEVEN O'CLOCK SO WITH
THAT.
CONSENT CALENDAR MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
BEFORE WE DO THAT ANYONE WISH TO
REMOVE AN ITEM FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDAR.
SEEING NONE MISTER SECRETARY
PLEASE READ THE CONSENT CALENDAR
[inaudible]
SENATE BILL. 374-792-95620
917-267-2772 862-923-4043 FIFTY
A 383-436-5695. 776-236-4087.
357-817-82780.
SIX SEVEN NINETY AND OCCUR
RESOLUTION. ELEVEN TWENTY ONE
THIRTY TWO ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION 525-831-3650. FIVE
FIFTY SIX AND THE SOME
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION.
SIXTY SEVEN IS THERE ANY
OBJECTION TO SUBSTITUTING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL ON THE
CONSENT CALENDAR SEEING AND
HEARING NONE ICE.
THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS ZERO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR IS ADOPTED.
AT THIS POINT IN TIME -- WE'RE
GOING TO GO BACK AND LIFT THE
CALLS ON A NUMBER OF ITEMS.
WE WILL START WITH FILE ITEM.
NINE MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
NO FLY BYS THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO THAT MEASURE IS ADOPTED
FILE ITEM TEN SENATOR LEYVA THIS
BILL PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI ICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED FILE ITEM
ELEVEN SENATOR KIRBY HEROES THE
MEASURE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible] FOR JUST
[inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
NIELSEN I VICE TWENTY NINE NO
SEVEN THE MEASURE IS ADOPTED
FILE ITEM FIFTEEN SENATOR
STERN'S ITEM.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
NIELSEN.
HI.
VICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE IS ADOPTED FILE ITEM
TWENTY THREE SENATOR STORAGE
ITEM.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
GROVE [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
GROW BY.
WARLOCK.
I NIELSEN.
BY MARCH THIRTY EIGHT NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
TWENTY FIVE SENATOR HILLS
MEASURE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
GROVE NO.
MORE LOCK.
NO.
ICE TWENTY EIGHT KNOWS EIGHT THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM TWENTY
SEVEN SENATOR UMBERG SO I DON'T
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
GROWTH [inaudible]
I MORE LUCK [inaudible]
HI MORRELL.
I IS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO THE
MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM.
THIRTY NINE SENATOR WIENERS ITEM
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
HI NIELSEN.
HI THE VICE THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES FILE ITEM
FORTY THREE SENATOR JONES PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROVE.
HI MORE LOCK [inaudible]
BY NIELSEN.
BY MARCH THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSAGE FILE ITEM
FORTY FOUR CENTER MONNING PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
[inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROWTH.
HI MORE LUCK BY NIELSEN.
HI HIGHS THIRTY SEVEN NO ZERO
THE MEASURE PASSES THE LAST ITEM
ON CALL IS FILE ITEM FIFTY ONE
BY SENATOR HILL.
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ATKINS [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HI.
MORE LOCK.
HI NIELSEN.
THE FIVE ICE THIRTY SEVEN KNOWS
ZERO THE MEASURE PASSES
COLLEAGUES THIS IS THE TIME --
FOR COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS WE'LL
START WITH SENATOR DORADO YES
SUBCOMMITTEE.
FOUR IN. FIFTEEN MINUTES AFTER
WE ADJOURN IN ROOM.
TWENTY FORTY FROM TWENTY FORTY
SUBCOMMITTEE FOR TWENTY MINUTES.
AFTER ADJOURNMENT. FIFTEEN
MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENT SO.
ELEVEN FIFTEEN ANY OTHERS.
ANNOUNCEMENTS ANY OTHER
COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS SENATOR
ROTH.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT.
A BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE NUMBER ONE
AN EDUCATIONAL MEETING ROOM A
THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE TEN
MINUTES AFTER -- GERMAN. ONE
THIRTEEN THIRTY ONE NINETY ONE
FOR SUBCOMMITTEE. ONE AT ELEVEN
TEN NEXT SENATOR ROBB OF SENATOR
SHOULD BE CENTER PAN FOLLOWED BY
CENTER Y. KOWSKI.
I THANK YOU US SENATE BUDGET
FISCAL REVIEW SO CAN BE NUMBER
THREE AND HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES TO BE MEETING IN ROOM --
FORTY TWO OH THREE TWENTY
MINUTES AFTER ADJOURNMENTS
ELEVEN TWENTY FOUR HEALTH AND
HUMAN SERVICES FROM.
FORTY TWO OH THREE SENATOR Y.
KOWSKI FOLLOWED BY SENATOR
SKINNER MEN PRESENT BUDGET SUB
TWO WILL MEET UPON ADJOURNMENT
IN ROOM -- ONE ONE THREE TODAY
VERY GOOD ELEVEN A. M. FOR SUB
THREE IN ROOM ONE ONE THREE
SENATOR SKINNER.
THANK YOU -- BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
FIVE ONE OF A THE PUBLIC SAFETY
AND JUDICIARY WILL MEET AT
ELEVEN FIFTEEN IN ROOM. ONE
FIFTEEN ONE THIRTEEN ROOM ONE
THIRTEEN AT ELEVEN FIFTEEN
SUBCOMMITTEE FIVE AND WITH THAT
WE WILL GO TO ADJOURN IN
MEMORIES BACK -- TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE TIME FOR
CHURNING MEMORY WE'LL START WITH
SENATOR DERON SO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR.
PRESIDENT -- AND AB.
ARE RICE TO ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF
MY GOOD FRIEND BLAZE ANTHONY BON
PAIN.
HE PASSED AWAY ON APRIL EIGHTH
TWO WEEKS PRIOR TO HIS NINETIETH
BIRTHDAY.
BUT IT WAS AN INTERNATIONALLY
KNOWN AND INFLUENTIAL PEACE AND
JUSTICE ACTIVIST.
BORN IN CLEVELAND OHIO TO
ITALIAN IMMIGRANTS HE PRODUCED
AND HOSTED THE POPULAR SUNDAY
RADIO SHOW FOR FIFTY YEARS WORLD
FOCUS ON OF RADIO KPFK IN LOS
ANGELES.
A COLLEAGUE OF SAYS OUR JOB IS
IN THE LETTERS WORKED ON THEIR
EARLY SEVENTIES HE AUTHORED AND
CO FOUNDER OF CO FOUNDED.
THE NONPROFIT OFFICE OF THE
AMERICAS WITH HIS WIFE TERESA HE
PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN RAISING
AWARENESS OF GOVERNMENT --
DIRECTED VIOLENCE THROUGHOUT
CENTRAL AMERICA IN THE EIGHTIES
BY LEADING DELEGATIONS OF
POLITICIANS ACTIVISTS
CELEBRITIES AND STUDENTS ON
TRIPS TO NAY GOT AYE WHILE.
HE WAS ORDAINED A PRIEST IN
NINETEEN FIFTY EIGHT AND THE
TOWARD THE U. S. AS A MERRY NO
REGIONAL DIRECTOR.
HE WAS THEN SENT TO WHAT THE
BALLOT TO RUN A MERRY NO PROGRAM
WAS LATER INSTRUCTED TO LEAVE
THE COUNTRY WHEN THE WATER
MAULING GOVERNMENT ARGUED THAT
HE WAS GING BEYOND HIS ROLE AS
A PRIEST. FOR STANDING UP FOR
THE RIGHTS OF THE INDIGENOUS
COMMUNITY AND WHAT THE MULLAH.
HE RETURNED TO HIS PARENTS HOME
IN LOS ANGELES TO BEGIN THIS
POST CHURCH LIFE.
AS DIRECTOR OF THE OFFICE OF
AMERICANS IN HIS WIFE THAT IS SO --
HAVE COMMITTED THEIR ENTIRE
LIVES TO PEACE AND NON VIOLENCE
I AM VERY PERSONALLY GRATEFUL
FOR ALL THAT BLAZE HAS TAUGHT ME.
HE WAS A DEDICATED LOVING FATHER
AND GRANDFATHER HE IS SURVIVED
BY HIS WIFE TERESA DAUGHTER
COLLEEN SUN BLAZED.
MARTIN AND SIX GRANDCHILDREN
PLEASE JOIN ME IN HONORING
BLAZES LEGACY AND SENDING OUR
HOT HEARTFELT CONDOLENCES TO HIS
FAMILY AND FRIENDS THANK YOU
THANK YOU SENATOR.
SO AND OUR SINCERE CONDOLENCES
TO THE FAMILY AND TO A LIFE WELL
LIVED.
AND WITH THAT [inaudible]
OF THE CENTER CUBBY ERA DO YOU
WISH TO DO AN INTERNAL MEMORY WE
WILL LAND WITH A AND A TURN IN
MEMORY FOR ELLEN TAUSCHER.
SATURDAY CABALLERO THANK YOU
MADAM.
UP PRESIDENT.
ROBERT LEON -- PASSED AWAY ON
APRIL TWENTY SEVENTH OF THIS
YEAR.
HE WAS A CHERISHED COMMUNITY
MEMBER A US CITIZEN IN A LOCAL
HEROINE KINGSBURG.
ROBERT ROBERT JANA WAS BORN AND
DIED ON THE FAMILY FARMING
KINGSBURG HE WAS A YOUNG
JAPANESE AMERICANS DURING WORLD
WAR TWO AND WAS CONSIDERED AN
EASIER SECOND GENERATION MEMBER
OF THE JAPANESE AMERICAN
COMMUNITY.
HE WAS A VARSITY ATHLETE IN
THREE SPORTS BASKETBALL FOOTBALL
AND TRACK A KINGSBURG HIGH
SCHOOL AND IN NINETEEN FORTY TWO
HE AND HIS FAMILY WERE FORCED TO
RELOCATE FROM KINGSBURG. TO THE
HEALER RIVER WAR RELOCATION
CENTER IN ARIZONA ALONG WITH
THIRTEEN THOUSAND OTHER JAPANESE
AMERICANS.
THE CENTER WAS AN ISOLATED
INTERNMENT CAMP WITH BERWICK'S
AND BARBED WIRE LOCATED ON THE
HILLA RIVER INDIAN RESERVATION.
HE MET THIS INHUMANE AND
DEGRADING TREATMENT WITH GRACE
AND DIGNITY AS DID HIS FAMILY.
AND THE AND AS HE PRACTICE
THROUGHOUT HIS LIFE.
IN NINETEEN FORTY FOUR AFTER TWO
YEARS IN THE CAMP HE ANSWERED
THE CALL TO DUTY AND JOIN THE
FOUR HUNDRED AND FORTY SECOND
REGIMENTAL COMBAT TEAM.
AN INTRUSION INFANTRY UNIT AT
THE U. S. ARMY THE MOST
DECORATED MILITARY UNIT IN U. S.
HISTORY. FOUR FORTY SECOND SAW
HEAVY COMBAT DURING WORLD WAR
TWO AND PERFORMED MANY HEROIC
ACTS INCLUDING RESCUING A LOS
BATTALION A REGIMEN THAT HAVE
BEEN FULLY CUT OFF AND
SURROUNDED BY GERMAN FORCES.
WHEN ROBERT SPOKE OF THIS RESCUE
MISSION MISSION HE SAID WE
DIDN'T COUNT THE COST WE
EXECUTED OUR MISSION NO MATTER
WHAT?
WE KNEW WE WERE THE LAST CHANCE
TO GET THEM OUT.
I REMEMBER AT THE BATTALION
YELLING GO FOR BROKE AS WE
CHARGE UP THE MOUNTAIN IN THE
FACE OF FIERCE ENEMY FIRE.
YOU COULDN'T RETREAT BECAUSE IF
YOU DID IT MEANT YOUR BROTHERS
DIED IN VAIN SO WE ALWAYS PUSH
FORWARD.
AFTER THE WAR ROBERT YANO
CONTINUE TO PUSH FOR WOULD
WITHOUT LOOKING BACK HE HAD
HOPED TO GO TO COLLEGE UPON HIS
RETURN BUT HE WAS TASKED WITH
TAKING OVER THE FAMILY FARM.
WEARING FRUIT TREES AND GRAPES
FOR RAISINS AND HE DID SO UNTIL
HIS DEATH.
IN NINETEEN FORTY NINE HE
MARRIED PATRICIA YAKKING MOTO
AND HAD TWO CHILDREN CHRISTINE
AND RANDALL. FOR TWO DECADES HE
SPOKE WITH STUDENTS IN KINGS
BIRD AND THROUGHOUT THE VALLEY
AS HE SHARED STORIES OF
SACRIFICEAND THE COURAGE OF HIS
GENERATION.
HE SHARED HIS STORIES WITH
CHILDREN AND FELT THE BY
EDUCATING THEM WE COULD PREVENT
THE JAPANESE INTERNMENT FROM
EVER HAPPENING AGAIN.
ROBERT WOULD OFTEN SAY AFTER
SPEAKING THAT IT WAS THE LAST
TIME AND THEN AND NOW THE
REQUEST WOULD COME AND HE'D SAY
OKAY BUT THIS IS REALLY THE LAST
TIME.
IN TWO THOUSAND TEN HE WAS
PRESENTED WITH THE CONGRESSIONAL
GOLD MEDAL ALONG SIDE EIGHTY
NINE OTHER SURVIVING MEMBERS OF
THE ONE HUNDRED AND FOUR HUNDRED
AND FORTY SECOND REGIMENT COMBAT
TEAMS.
THE CONGRESSIONAL GOLD MEDAL IS
THE HIGHEST CIVILIAN HONOR GIVEN
BY THE UNITED STATES CONGRESS
AND IS AWARDED FOR TWO PERSONS
WHO HAVE MADE A MAJOR AND LONG
STANDING IMPACT ON AMERICAN
HISTORY AND CULTURE.
ROBERT YANO TRAVEL THE WORLD BUT
HE ALSO ALWAYS SAID THERE'S NO
PLACE LIKE KINGS BURKE HE WAS
EXTRAORDINARILY HELPFUL BUT HE
DEDICATED HIS LIFE TO SPREADING
THE MESSAGE THAT WE SHOULD NEVER
REPEAT THE MISTAKES OF HISTORY.
HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS TWO
CHILDREN FIVE GRANDCHILDREN AND
ONE GREAT GRANDSON.
THEY ALL OF HIS CHILDREN AND
GRANDCHILDREN WENT TO HIGH
SCHOOL IN KINGS BURKE AND MANY
ARE ACCOMPLISHED ASH ATHLETES
PLEASE JOIN ME IN RECOGNIZING
THE LIFE OF ROBERT YOUNG.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND COVER YOUR
OWN PLEASE MAKE SURE THAT YOU
BRING -- HIS NAME FORWARD SO WE
CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE HIS
EXTRAORDINARY LIFE.
AND NOW OUR FINAL ADJOURNED IN
MEMORY IS TO A FORMER COLLEAGUE.
OF ELLEN TAUSCHER WHO PASSED
AWAY OVER THE LAST FEW WEEKS
SENATOR DODD THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT FELL
SENATORS I ASK YOU TO JOIN ME IN
REMEMBERING AND CELEBRATING THE
LIFE.
OF FORMER CONGRESS WOMAN.
ELLEN TAUSCHER.
I HAD THE GREAT HONOR OF GETTING
TO KNOW ELIN OVER THE YEARS.
SHE SIR CALIFORNIANS A MEMBER OF
OUR CONGRESSIONAL DELEGATION.
FOR THIRTEEN YEARS AND I HAVE
THE PLEASURE OF REPRESENTING
MANY OF THE COMMUNITIES THAT SHE
SERVED.
ELLEN WAS AN UNABASHED MODERATE
AND WAS A MASTER.
AT BRINGING PEOPLE TOGETHER IN
ACHIEVING RESULTS.
IN TWO THOUSAND NINE SHE WAS
APPOINTED UNDERSECRETARY OF
STATE FOR ARMS CONTROL AND
INTERNATIONAL SECURITY AFFAIRS.
HE PLAYED A KEY ROLE IN IS IT
CHEATING THE NEW START TREATY OF
TWO THOUSAND TEN WITH LIMITED
LARGE PLATFORM TO NUCLEAR
WARHEADS.
REDUCING US AND RUSSIAN NUCLEAR
STOCKPILES TO THEIR LOWEST LEVEL
IN SIXTY YEARS.
ELLEN WAS A TRAILBLAZER EVEN
BEFORE ENTERING NATIONAL
POLITICS SHE GREW UP IN NEW
JERSEY THE DAUGHTER OF A U. F.
C. W. REPRESENTATIVE.
AND SECRETARY AFTER GRADUATING
FROM SETON HALL UNIVERSITY ELLEN
WENT ON TO WORK IN BOND TRADING
ON WALL STREET.
AT AGE TWENTY FIVE SHE BECAME
THE YOUNGEST WOMAN TO EVER HOLD
A SEAT ON THE NEW YORK STOCK
EXCHANGE.
SHE MOVED TO CALIFORNIA IN THE
LATE NINETEEN EIGHTIES AND SOON
GOT INVOLVED IN POLITICS PLAY A
KEY ROLE IN.
DIE IN FIVE SITES FIRST -- TO U.
S. SENATE CAMPAIGNS.
SHE ESTABLISHED A TAUSCHER
FOUNDATION WHICH HAS HELPED
ELEMENTARY SCHOOLS PROVIDE
COMPUTERS IN INTERNET ACCESS TO
STUDENTS.
MOST RECENTLY SHE WAS CHAIRWOMAN
OF GOVERNOR JERRY BROWN'S
MILITARY ADVISORY COUNCIL IT SHE
SERVED AS A UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA REGENT.
WHILE REMAINING ACTIVE IN
POLITICS.
OUR STATE NATION OR WORLD ARE
MUCH BETTER TODAY FOR ELLEN
TAUSCHER SERVICE SHE IS SURVIVED
BY A DAUGHTER CATHERINE IN MANY
LOVED ONES PLEASE JOIN ME IN A
JOURNEY IN MEMORY.
OF CONGRESSWOMAN ELLEN TAUSCHER.
THANK YOU SENATOR DOT ON THIS TO
TURN IN MEMORY SENATOR GLAZER.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS I WANT TO THANK MY
COLLEAGUE FROM NAPA FOR
RECOGNIZING THIS EXTRAORDINARY
WOMAN.
LEADER IN OUR STATE AND OUR
NATION HE WAS AN ICON IN CONTRA
COSTA COUNTY -- SHE BROUGHT
BUSINESS ACT CAME INTO THE WORK
OF PUBLIC POLICY AS A
CONGRESSWOMAN -- AS A HIGH
RANKING OFFICIAL IN THE STATE
DEPARTMENT AS THE UC REGENTS.
I SHE HAD INCREDIBLE
INTELLIGENCE HE HAD GREAT.
STRENGTH OF INDEPENDENCE AND I'D
AND A DESIRE TO BRING PEOPLE
TOGETHER AND LEAD WITH THAT
GREAT BIPARTISAN SPIRIT THAT WAS --
IT PRECEDED BY.
BY ALL SHE'S A EXTRAORDINARY
PERSON THAT WE WILL MISS THERE'S
JUST SO MANY FIENDS BOTH IN
CONTRA COSTA THROUGHOUT.
THIS COUNTRY -- AND OVERALL I
THINK DEEPLY SADDENED BY THIS
LOSS AND WITH THAT I JOIN MY
COLLEAGUE IN ASKING THAT WE
DURING HER WONDERFUL MEMORY.
THANK YOU SENATOR GLAZER AND TO
HONOR ONE OF FOUR STATES GREAT
SHE ROSE -- I WOULD ASK YOU JUST
TAKE A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
IF YOU WOULD [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
IF THERE IS NO OTHER BUSINESS
SENATOR WILK THE DESK IS CLEAR.
THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
MEMBERS VERY PRODUCTIVE FLOOR
SESSION TODAY I WISH YOU ALL
SAFE TRAVELS HOME TO BE WITH
YOUR CONSTITUENTS -- THE SENATE
WILL BE IN RECESS UNTIL THREE
THIRTY PM WHICH TIME THE
ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE MADE
AND WE WILL RECONVENE BACK HERE
NEXT MONDAY AT TWO PM.
HAVE A GREAT WEEKEND THANK YOU
SENATOR WILK.
SENATE WILL BE RECESSED UNTIL
THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH TIME
THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL BE
MADE WE RECONVENE MONDAY.
AT TWO PM HAPPY WEEKEND